we got new merch some new colorways uh
in the be good to yourself collection
we've got hoodies in Plum and Moss we've
also got t-shirts in lilac moss and Blue
Mist hope you enjoy those those are good
colors
get that hitter and more at
theovanstore.com
I want to let you know that we have some
new tour dates to announce
January 11th and 12th in Grand Junction
Colorado we've added a new show there
January 13th Pueblo Pueblo Colorado
January 14th Denver we have two shows
there January 15th down in Fort Collins
Colorado we are excited to be at the
fort
and March 1st 3rd and 4th in Boston
Massachusetts and March 2nd in Medford
Massachusetts those are all available at
theovan.com
t-o-u-r and that will be the return of
the Rat tour
today's guest has been a fixture
um in the uh rap and hip-hop Community
um he was a part of a lot of our
adolescents and young adulthoods
um
he's
he's a new friend and I'm grateful to
spend time with him and hear hear about
his journey as a Entertainer and as a
human today's guest is Mr Bubba Sparks
[Music]
[Music]
I've been singing
[Applause]
it's called the Sparks baby what's up
big deal Staying Alive man staying alive
staying alive pleasantly present yeah
trying to be dude that's a big thing is
trying to stay present for me I get so
caught up sometimes and thinking about
everything that I need to do or or
things I haven't done and I will get
what's that they always say you probably
heard at some of the same places that
we've been uh if you've got one foot in
tomorrow and one foot and yesterday
you're pissing and [ __ ] all over
today
yeah man I got I got a few sayings for
you yeah I bet we probably have a lot of
the same so you because you and I kind
of connected over like talking about
sobriety right right you know
um can you move this mic just over no no
you don't have to move but you could
move this whatever as long as it's near
your beak yeah there we go and yeah feel
free to move it or whatever to do with
my hands
there's no real way to you know okay I
was doing Ricky Bobby oh
yes so how's it what's that been like in
your life man man it's just been a back
and forth Journey you know what I'm
saying I mean it's just been you know
I've I've had some periods of of
recovery you know I'm saying that I've
had some periods of sobriety you know
I'm saying that weren't necessarily like
filled with great recovery you know
saying there's a difference as you know
you know I'm saying sometimes I was just
kind of white knuckling it you know and
sometimes and then sometimes I'm kind of
just either on the way to to you know
things getting bad or like on the way to
things back getting good you know what
I'm saying at what point is like the
that that turn forward you know what I'm
saying so to speak on the racetrack you
know yeah but you know I just um
I went to treatment back in in February
you know and it was it was good but I
wouldn't claim to be sober right now was
it a 30 was it what what is it like I
mean I did 35 days of inpatient you know
what I'm saying it was kind of weird
because all the coveted protocols so
like you know how normally when you go
to treatment you can like um get to go
to outside meetings and all that stuff
and you can find a sponsor that way and
all that stuff we were literally like
stuck in this one whole this house like
for it was a cold months so it was like
kind of it was a good deal to be stuck
inside but man it got kind of Stir Crazy
in that joint for sure and was it all
men in there no there was some women but
they had like a different little house
that they actually would sleep in and
they had to go there like after eight
o'clock they had to go get in their
house and but I ain't gonna say I heard
tale of some some intermingling after
hours you know what I'm saying but yeah
but uh yeah I definitely wasn't on that
that type of vibe I have you know in
other uh trips to treatment I've kind of
you know been all about the the female
um patience
yeah especially man if I'm coming off of
pills I want to pet something you know
man well it's just anytime you know you
we feel that hole that internal hole
with external anything you know what I'm
saying and so it's like man if you take
away what I what my primary like tool I
was using to try to fill that hole even
though it was just ultimately making the
hole bigger but if you just if you take
that whatever thing I was using I might
have to find something else it might be
cheeseburgers yeah I'm saying it might
be gambling it might be women you know
it might be men whatever yeah damn bro I
know I haven't been there yet yeah me
neither dude you hit me with the wrong
eight ball
man I just I don't know I just never had
that inclination if I was if I was gay I
would just be gay yeah you know what I'm
saying it wouldn't really I mean I can't
say that growing up it might not have
been like uh kind of a tormenting type
thing up in the rural South you know
like yeah
back then but to be honest with you like
being a a white rapper from LaGrange
Georgia you know saying it was it was
some of the same type of like you know I
don't say oppression but just ridicule
that you face you know I never even
thought about that you know yeah I guess
people yeah people probably really would
like think you trying to Blacken up or
something like that well it's kind of
like not really accepted by either side
you know saying it's where I grew up
LaGrange Georgia shout out to trap
County but um it's pretty much 50 black
50 white you know what I'm saying and
and so yeah definitely the white side
wasn't really too you know saying like
open-minded to the Prospect of me being
a rapper at that time but you know the
hood side the black folks really wasn't
too receptive either it's not like they
were just waiting well you know with
open arms as far as that like come be a
rapper over here because well you were
early and tell me you were like I mean
you were dang you were like the dang uh
Neil Armstrong out there you was like
one of the first man on the moon yeah
yeah he was like one of the first wiggas
on the moon kind of in a way you know no
I mean as far as like you know a country
boy from the south you know or did they
have that I don't know they didn't have
it no that's and that's been part of the
journey like is there was no reference
point you know what I'm saying like I
grew up all like Outcast I was heavily
influenced by Outkast Goodie Mob the
organized noise the dungeon family so
that was the closest thing because they
were the first people to kind of like
rip Georgia you know I'm saying period
that specifically Atlanta but for me I
was I was brought up in the country
about 60 miles down the road from
Atlanta oh damn and so yeah there was
and just being a white boy or whatever
there was definitely nobody for me to
look at even though I did learn from a
lot of other white rappers that were
successful starting with the Beastie
Boys you know going on to like Everlast
House of Pain even third base to some
degree
um but then Eminem you know I'm saying
it was right Eminem was about a year
before me you know what I'm saying and
when he came I was like that's
Perfection right there the way that was
executed so like but I but I knew you
know shout out to Vanilla Ice
um he's actually my dog like I've done
shows with him and we've we've had a
ball but he's a cool cat I've met him a
few times yeah he's a good dude man and
um but at that time there was like after
his Ice Ice Baby rain kind of like when
he sold like 15 million albums which you
can't take everybody was listening
everybody was jamming Ice Ice Baby I
don't care what nobody says now oh even
Vietnamese are like you know you know
man everybody had it hey you know
projects albums don't sell 15 million
singles don't sell 30 million or
whatever is sold without everybody
liking this [ __ ] you know dude everybody
like that [ __ ] everybody got the big
pants when you really hit when you
affect people's you know when you go
through their ears and come out their
clothing I mean I remember so many white
boys and I wasn't quite old enough to
attempt a stunt like this but I remember
white boys getting even like the little
haircut that he had and [ __ ] like and it
was just like dang man you were so cool
you got a Vanilla Ice haircut you know
what I'm saying but that wasn't really
something I was on but just to keep
going there was some kind of
discrepancies uh with his story about
where he was from and what he was
representing as far as being a hood kid
or whatever and so after that I kind of
just learned it was like a lull it was
like a five or six year period where
there was nobody was checking for white
rappers you know what I'm saying but I I
knew like you just got to represent who
you are you know what I'm saying like
everything that's in in the spirit of
hip-hop and where hip-hop comes from and
like the principles you know the guiding
principles are based on like you know
just truly truly accurately honestly
represent who you are where you come
from and what it was like there and tell
your story honestly you know what I'm
saying and and that's that's gonna work
you know what I'm saying if you do it
you figure out a way to make it dope and
so I I had developed that within myself
because like my first raps I ever wrote
like in 1992 like in my mom's kitchen
table in the ninth grade we're like was
just rolling in the in benzo letting the
bass drop when five [ __ ] rolled
by in a drop top like you know talking
about like boys in the hood like yeah
yeah because I didn't know how to and
that was part of the what you're talking
about like the whole journey of me
trying to figure out how within using
hip-hop is the is the outlet expressing
who I was and where I came from you know
growing up on a farm you know saying in
LaGrange yeah but some of the animals
got gold chains on them I just I never
cared about music music was all around
me I had an older brother that loved
like metal bands like Iron Maiden big
shout out to Russ iron maiden's his
favorite man all-time bands so he was
into that type of music then I had my
oldest brother Jay shout out to Jay he
liked like a parliament Funk Camelot you
know what I'm saying George Clinton all
that kind of stuff he had P-Funk and
then my dad likes like throwback country
you know traditional country and my mama
just likes to dance you know what I'm
saying so music was all around but it
just didn't speak to me you know what
I'm saying I didn't care about it it was
just something in the background but
when I heard them somebody say hey we
want some put when I heard that I was
like what is that yeah then when I heard
boys in the hood when I heard too short
I was like what the [ __ ] is this you
know what I know you had maybe you
didn't even know you had that man it
just spoke I knew it was good when I
heard uh Brass Monkey by the Beastie
Boys yeah I heard it and it was just
like man this is going to be a part of
my life forever I just feel it it just
speaks to me like I don't know the raw
expression the 808 drum like man it was
a lot to do with that 808 honestly man
like for real because that wasn't really
a part the boom bap was kind of like
like the New York wave of hip-hop but
when the West Coast time we got his turn
was like too short in wa like that 808
drum was rattling you know what I'm
saying so dude I remember yeah when some
of that [ __ ] came through our
neighborhood because I probably grew up
I didn't grow up country I just grew up
in like a rural kind of white area right
because Louisiana doesn't get like a
redneck Vibe Louisiana is just it's a
lot of like grandchildrenal ages
you got Cajun people you got a lot of
mix kind of like a lot of yellow skin
kind of like light-skinned black dudes
you got some kind of dog Creole type
yeah you got some people just [ __ ]
you don't know what color they are bro
they don't even know [ __ ] nah
Louisiana's a different kind of place
now they got a lot of pirates
grandchildren the Pirates and [ __ ] like
that you know old broadnecks you know
there's there's a country rapper that's
doing this thing right now that um he's
from Monroe Louisiana and he's got hit
they call him Broadneck broadnecks
that's his last name yeah John I think
it's John brognecks or whatever but he's
representing Louisiana he's got that
Louisiana flavor about about the way he
does his thing but it's like kind of
country white boy you know Louisiana
genotype flavor which I wouldn't call it
like country country like Farm type
country it's just more like swampy yeah
yeah so you so you're mute so yeah you
were just trying to express yourself
really yeah and then it was just it's
kind of like a puzzle too you're just
trying to figure out how to fit the
pieces together and make it seem cool
ultimately you know what I'm saying
because
I mean there are some pretty interesting
Dynamics to to Rural Life you know I'm
saying that
um that maybe some people just aren't
typically aware of you know what I'm
saying but just how to it's not now I'm
not trying to say that violence in the
community and all that stuff is is cool
it's a terrible thing but ultimately if
you're representing yourself as a person
that made it persevered and made it
through that and that's your testimony
of like you know I'm saying that's cool
right I'm saying and it's and it's hard
you know what I'm saying but basically I
just I was like well this is it you know
I'm saying I gotta just give it what I
have to offer you know what I'm saying
and and I just told the story of
of of what I've been through and what my
life had been like and you know it was
enough people that related to it for me
to be able to keep doing this as a job
without having to get a real job for 20
something years you know what I'm saying
so yeah dude everybody I mean I [ __ ]
it was crazy man when you hit the scene
it was just
it was special man it was special man
did what was the some of the pressure of
that like because
um yet they just didn't have anything
like you all of a sudden you're like
kind of mixing Two Worlds you're
probably not like yeah maybe some I
could imagine maybe especially where
you're from some white people could see
like oh this is too
this is too black for us and the hood
the hood you're never the hooded [ __ ]
is you're never Hood enough even if you
like the hood will always be like you
never hood or no you know it's like
there's always that even in the black
community at the end of the day when you
just are being you you know what I'm
saying like and I and I never
compromised me you know and I really
didn't I never did there were some
things that I might have done that I
would have preferred to have highlighted
other aspects of of who I really am but
any there's nothing I did that wasn't
you know A Certain Shade of like who I
am you know what I'm saying like
truthfully and so it's kind of like just
being at peace you know I went through
so much when I was younger as far as
like trying to really just figure out
like because I mean to say that people
didn't support me
um in my my um my pursuit of this of rap
music hip-hop as a career would be a
pretty big understatement you know I
would say more like people didn't even
kind of like stop chuckling behind my
back until I had actually like I was on
MTV you know what I'm saying so I was
well accustomed and adjusted to like
people not not supporting me you know
they have to be that that that
self-propelling you know type deal well
that happens I think with a lot of like
I remember when I was a comedian like it
was like
or until like you somebody sees you want
something you are just some dude you
were like some guy that don't want to
get a real job and everybody just thinks
you're full of you know what I'm saying
like everybody just thinks at the end of
the day because
you know I mean I'm a creative person
you know what I'm saying and I I played
football and that's like the big deal
like where I grew up like high school
football you know it's like the Friday
Night Lights type of deal for sure you
know I was pretty good at football my
best friend Steve Hernan shout out to
him he was great at football you know
what I'm saying he was one of the top
100 uh highest recruited players in the
country went to Georgia was all SEC
played in the NFL for seven years but so
I love football football's my first love
to be honest with you and it was
interesting because music was actually
his first love and uh we ended up living
vicariously through one another but
um when I saw how
I was like man he so he's what the deal
deal is and I'm just not quite dead you
know what I'm saying so
man what could I be great great at you
know I'm saying I had never bumped my I
bumped my head on the ceiling as far as
my potential with football pretty pretty
early but I was like man I just really
think I can do the music thing I just
the first time I ever sat down to write
a rap I was like man I just got a knack
for this for just putting words together
making them rhyme and just being clever
and just I don't know I just always
somewhere deep down in my heart even
though I tried to do other things
because it wasn't easy like I said there
was no acceptance for it you know we all
crave being accepted you know what I'm
saying on some level or another by the
people around us and nobody was really
my closest friends like big Steve like
he he believed in me 100 you know so I'd
be up at University of Georgia I ended
up moving up to Athens uh Georgia and
being up there like you know freestyling
after football games and stuff and like
all the guys on the team you know what
I'm saying just like my Andy's what they
call me back then and just like Andy
flow phone one time flow phone one time
you know what I'm saying like and just
all the all those guys being up there
and just being like before the head I
thought you was the iPod no doubt and
like I I as far as battling like
everybody would try to go back home and
find the best rapper in their little
area and get them to come up get him
I'll bring his little ass I don't know
he gonna serve your boy and then you
know what I'm saying it just wasn't
happening you know what I'm saying it
just so I would sit there and literally
go back and just write and write you
know what I'm saying because I've never
been a freestyler because I didn't grow
up around other people rapping you know
what I'm saying so people developed that
freestyling ability I think when they're
in groups of people rapping but it was a
long time before I was around other
people that were like seriously even you
know rapping putting words together like
that so when you like so how did then
you start to take off how did your
career how did you how did it go from
that where you're just kind of rapping
and becoming like acclaimed amongst
people in Georgia amongst like after
parties and stuff like that before
social media how did you get to that
next that's a good question because I
always tell people now like this era the
way it is
I don't even I wouldn't know where to
start telling somebody how to get on you
know I'm saying how to make it happen
you know just when people ask me for
advice I'm like look just pray that this
is what God wants for you if it's what
you really want you know and and burn
Bridges like and I don't mean burn
bridges in terms of relationships but in
the pursuit of this thing if you leave
yourself out and I know you know this as
far as like the comedy thing too if you
leave yourself out at some point you're
going to take one of them you know what
I'm saying because it's tough you know
yeah you know and so I I burnt my some
bridges as coaches Georgia Kirby Smart
would say burn the boats you know what
I'm saying like there was just nowhere
for me to go other than this you know
what I'm saying if this didn't happen I
shudder to think what what might have
been you know it was at a certain number
of years in especially it's like when
you get up to like 25 20 people are like
what's going on you're not in college
you don't have this degree you don't
have a child you don't have a family
people are like you better show
something you know and my best friend
was like playing football at Georgia and
you know he was on the way to the NFL
and it was honestly it hurt me so bad
because I loved him so much and was so
supportive of him and I now believe
believe that that was God preparing me
you know because like I learned how to
not be a hater you know what I'm saying
and a lot of people probably looked at
me definitely looked at me as like a
hindrance on him even you know what I'm
saying like like you know Steve beard if
you know if uh just get away from old
Andy you know what I'm saying like kind
of looked at me as like the loser but
Steve he never bought into that he never
subscribed to that you know saying he
was always like tell people like you
know he gonna do something big I don't
know when it's gonna be or what exactly
it's gonna be maybe this music thing
maybe not he gonna do something big you
know he always believed in me never
blinked and then had you had that kind
of belief before in your life had you
had someone you feel like believe in you
that like like that like um no other
than him honestly I mean it's not that
my my parents and his parents they it
was love you know what I'm saying but it
was like it was just so far beyond their
realm of comprehension you know that it
might even be remotely feasible for
something like that to happen especially
being a white boy and coming from from
down there but I just always looked at
it like this I always had like this
innate feeling like hey I'm just I'm
gonna do something special I'm special
I'm Different you know I'm not not in a
bad way because I've never not been
humble but just like you know just
really feeling like there's just
something out there waiting for me that
I just gotta find it and pluck it out of
the sky or whatever and um and so I um
I just basically like I didn't never
think
sometimes I felt like
you know it was going to be something
like because my my fallback plan was
being a high school history teacher in a
high school football coach oh damn I'd
love to see you [ __ ] remix
to Civil War Dog yeah I love to see that
I got a crazy theory on that too I'm
like you know like you know when you
have like the feeling this is a
tangential yeah there's people listening
just because people right now are
stacking shell they're driving Amazon
y'all Rock Steady out there but um as
far as like man I just I feel like in
the future like I think you know how we
get that feeling like everybody says
like you just know something's in the
room with you or you like hear something
crazy or whatever I've kind of developed
a theory on this and maybe you I mean I
like to hear your your thoughts on it so
I think that in the future you know like
how in history class now you know like
we go through books and look at pictures
and and listening speeches or whatever
of these that Mark these certain you
know historical events or whatever I
think in the future
the reason that we hear these weird
things and like it's like these I don't
know what you would call it not ghosts
but like some of them probably are
mistaken for ghosts I think in the
future time travel is actually possible
and people come back and like can
actually be present but it's like in a
different dimension so they can like see
it but they're not really present
they're like in danger and actually be
on the battlefield at Gettysburg and
stuff like that oh wow yeah that's
that's just something that so you're
saying like in the future you could have
like Gettysburg yeah basically people
Class A whole field they just sit there
looking at the Battle actually taking
place but see they're not the the whole
background they don't know that they're
there in the whole no yeah the people
that are fighting the battle don't but
like the whole Back to the Future thing
and like about like you know messing it
up and all that stuff that's not that's
not a threat because you're like in a
different dimension right you know what
I'm saying so you can observe it but
you're not actually present but man I
really think that's I get through some
like secret drywall or something like
they don't know yeah it's just you're in
a different some kind of different you
know like dude I used to think look I
love this [ __ ] I used to think that so
people had CDs and they try you know
this and that people had uh
I always thought that they were gonna
come out with a dashboard that was like
uh some sort of a screen right in a
vehicle and you would put you would just
press in whatever you wanted to listen
to and then like uh Bubba spark would
come and perform on your dashboard like
a hologram yeah I always thought that
that would be the next thing like if you
wanted to watch AC DC you would just
type it in yeah and then damn they would
come out there and actually you're just
driving and they're right there you know
I mean that's like the next step in the
evolution of just music videos and like
streaming period though you know what
I'm saying it's probably not
probably because they have those
Holograms like a Tupac I remember there
was like that that thing so I mean we
technology if you went back a hundred
years from from this like so if you went
back to 1920 somebody's mind I mean but
like so much more than you would if you
went from 1922 to 1822 right they
wouldn't be that shocked right exactly
like the world didn't change that much
but like that's a wheel [ __ ] but that's
just the evidence of the fact that
technology is evolving at a much more
rapid rate so imagine a hundred years
from now we can't comprehend it we
literally cannot comprehend it and so
dude you know what somebody was telling
me about com I was talking with someone
about this
and they had
what were you talking about you were
talking about a guy with a ladder
and you another guy said hey we one day
I think we could get to the Moon Yeah
and this dude could only think nah we
can't get to we can maybe get to the top
of a tree or something right but I'm not
doing a good job explaining uh anyway it
was something
we can't comprehend yeah things that
like it's like we don't have the words
for sometimes right and it's beyond our
brain even because we're still thinking
within the limitations three-dimensional
thing of this world we're thinking of
our limitations one of the hardest
things I ever saw was like the way uh I
forget I was watching something this is
probably 10 15 years ago but they were
explaining the difference because you
know mathematics is like proven that
there's like nine Dimensions you know
I'm saying like we just aren't aware of
them or haven't discovered them or
figured out how to interpret them or you
know or just see them or be present in
whatever the case is but
so like you know if if we lived in a
two-dimensional world my finger coming
at you
would just look like a DOT
but because it's a three-dimensional
world you can see all sides of my finger
you know what I'm saying but imagine
this if there was some being
God perhaps some people might call that
being they could do time the same way
who's to say
you know what I'm saying what you're
saying yeah I like to like look all
around time like you know the time thing
this right right because time for us
just flows like this right but what if
some dudes go all around yeah just be
like okay this is like looking at it
from looking at uh 2022 from 2014. okay
now I'm gonna go look at 2022 from 2036.
see what I'm saying so I don't yeah I
wonder if there's other Realms we're
gonna cry like yeah I feel like that has
to be the next you would have to believe
that's what God would be you know what
I'm saying like because I remember when
I was real little
um
you know my Pops I wouldn't necessarily
call them like an intellectual but he's
he's a pretty smart guy you know what
I'm saying and he would say I'd be like
trying to get him to explain God to me
you know like you know he's because that
was a very inquisitive kid and he'd just
be like it's just beyond our realm of
comprehension you know that would shut
me up every time he's like you just
can't even understand it so you know
what I mean like and honestly like
that's the truth you know what I'm
saying like whatever it is we're talking
about whatever might be or could be or
could I mean we could evolve into it's
just hard to to know but I was listening
to something um the other day I watch a
lot of YouTube videos oh yeah man I'll
go down on YouTube did I love that one
with you and Randy Akins oh Rodney
Atkins Rodney Atkins Rodney man uh right
wreck right yeah right yeah I like
wrecking I like right right I really
really like wrecking that's what's up I
like recommend but I really I really
really did like write I don't know what
it was nah that was that was um a pretty
good example to me that's that's
something I don't know normally do as
far on the countryside that's like
country music
um we rap on it you know what I'm saying
like yeah I do I feel like I do country
hip-hop you know what I'm saying really
it should be called hip-hop country
because hip-hop is the first thing that
I've you know I'm saying that I'm got it
you know I I represent all things that I
am I'm white you know what I'm saying or
whatever I'm I'm country hip-hop but I'd
say I'm hip hop before I'm anything you
know what I'm saying because it's just
that the
uh hip-hop music and culture and it's
done so much for me I'm so grateful
you're all over the world but
it's just I just want to complete land
on that thought about uh about right
um some guys like big SMO Colt Ford I
would say those are kind of the like
forefathers of that sound you know what
I'm saying like where it's really just
more like country music just with some
rapping on it and it's dope and that
song was incredible shout out to Noah
Gordon uh who worked worked on writing
that song with us
um but yeah and Rodney I just come to
Nashville and that was kind of like the
2012 area of like when Florida Georgia
Line was first blowing up and the TV
show Nashville I was on you know so yeah
yeah Nashville was kind of like getting
that first like oh it's like becoming
like an international like cool place he
was putting this little skirt on yeah
what just redneck Hollywood anymore yeah
and so like
um you know and I came up here and and
you know Rodney Atkins he took a chance
on you know I'm saying it wasn't the
cool now like this uh genre bending
collaborations yeah now you got like
Morgan Wallen a little dirt yeah it's
it's kind of like it's it's uh just like
the norm see everything's real mixed up
but back then it was you know it was a
actually a kind of rolling the dice you
know what I'm saying with your career to
try something like that and to step over
that line and so I'm appreciative of the
people that did because you know country
I always sought to build a bridge
between people you know what I'm saying
between
um hip hop and Country the hood and you
know what I'm saying because lower class
people just aren't that different you
know what I'm saying that's the thing I
was thinking about next I always wonder
why don't uh I feel like what poor
because as a poor white kid the first
thing you wanted to be was black I felt
like yeah I mean I was a poor white when
I well I'm not a poor white kid anymore
I'm not a kid yeah you know you know and
I had some of the times I hate having
even made any money because I'm not
[ __ ] poor anymore I can't I can't
have the same feelings I had yeah no
there's nothing about that you know what
I'm saying celo says I kind of like
being po at least I know what my friends
here for you know what I'm saying oh wow
my mom used to say she would say if you
don't have anything they can't take
anything away from you she would say
that's right and it was kind of like you
really be about some [ __ ] when you ain't
got nothing else
bro you don't care when death don't even
seem like that bad of an alternative
[ __ ] me whatever you want to do man
ain't got no yeah nothing's gonna get
you it don't matter but for some reason
yeah when I think I've related so much I
feel like to poor black kids when I was
young and I think that it's also just a
thing like
we have Miss Pat on she says she's like
black people make things cool she said
um and I don't know if I agree about
that with everything for sure you know
black folks are creators I mean there's
you know there's there's nothing that
you could really if you look at you know
I mean all that's been created by black
folks in America I mean it's a lot when
it comes to artists oh yeah yeah you
know what I'm saying well they got more
art kind of built into them you know
even I feel like if you punch a black
dude a cool sound comes out of them you
know it's like but I just I I'm always a
little bit fascinated by what it is even
in my own life why I felt like I related
to poor but you know what I think though
I think a lot of times uh raw creativity
comes from poverty and oppression you
know what I'm saying from just the
struggle you know what I'm saying like
it's yeah maybe I like the ore because
poor black people always had a
when I was young they didn't even have
any rich black people they only had like
Michael worthy yeah Bill Cosby and maybe
like the Dallas Cowboys it felt like and
and you know they probably weren't even
that rich like you know what you would
what we thought was rich at that time
probably we wouldn't they probably were
making like half a million dollars a
year or something you know or maybe
because contracts weren't even that
lucrative back then you know what I'm
saying no The Producers were making all
the money back then I mean they really
had them boxed up but even like I
remember if they had like like the best
job a black person could get in our town
was probably like our teacher you know
like Baton Rouge this was in uh
Covington Louisiana so it's like coaches
yeah coaches uh now you see a lot more
like I went to the first black doctor I
that like about maybe seven months ago
going to the doctor and it was a black
guy I'd never been are you serious yeah
and I didn't mean anything but I know
there's black doctors but I just had
never been into one and I'm like is this
gonna I just I was like and then I'm
thinking black people their whole life
been going to White doctors what do they
think about that well you know I mean
just growing up in like because you know
this is the south is different than the
rest of the country like like there's a
black folks in pretty much every major
city yeah the difference in the South
and the rest of the country is
you go an hour outside into the country
in the South and it's still a bunch of
black folks you go an hour outside of
like uh Chicago Minneapolis yeah you
know what I'm saying or Milwaukee and
there's really not any black folks you
know what I'm saying that's a good point
so to speak and so I just feel I think
like Atlanta especially like with
Atlanta having spent that's kind of like
my that's my home major city you know
what I'm saying I lived in Atlanta for
that's where I live now you know so it's
like February started a damn City over
there I mean it's just you know and I
always tell people when I bump into like
uh black folks in Idaho or something
that just have never been around a lot
of other black folks I say you go live
in Atlanta for two years you know what
I'm saying and go experience a city it's
a black City not just in terms of like
the metro population being a lot of
black folks but also the infrastructure
you know what I'm saying the mayor's
black you know what I'm saying the the
city council you know the the a lot of
the policemen the sheriff you know what
I'm saying it's just it's that kind of
city and I tell white people in those
same areas that you know because you
ever notice like a lot of those like
hate groups and stuff would be like in
Idaho and you know the militias and all
that stuff and I'm like
they're no black when have you ever been
around black people to know you have a
problem with them you know what I'm
saying like you know but I tell I tell
you know white folks the same thing go
live in Atlanta for a couple years see
what it's like to be for that shoe to be
on the other the foot you know what I'm
saying of the foot and you should
experience that you know I'm saying
because I think that that just evolves
your perspective to a point where you
might look be a little more sympathetic
and empathetic of somebody you know what
I'm saying if you really
just
looked at the world the way they had
been forced to see it you know
yeah it's interesting I I just I guess I
was really just yeah I'm just thinking
about like why
I guess why I guess maybe it's a lot of
music I wonder what it was that made me
relate when I was real young I was in
this you know uh it was hip-hop man I'm
gonna tell you you know what I'm saying
hip-hop what it was hip-hop shaped a lot
of hearts and changed a lot of
um potentially racist
you know Hearts like I would say like
broke that cycle in families in the
South you know a lot of because I just
knew people that would otherwise I'd be
like man that joke was racist but I just
love Tupac so much they just couldn't be
you know what I'm saying that one thing
because they just love Tupac
hypothetically right so much it just
slowly changed their whole perspective
on on just black folks in general well
yeah you'd have like I always had this
Vision you'd have a dude out in his yard
just yelling me inward but then he
closed the door and he's in there
[ __ ] moonwalk right you know that's
the MTV generation you know what I'm
saying like yeah because you think about
it like people that grew up in the
that's why these these songwriters here
in Nashville when they write like every
genre is present you know what I'm
saying they're bringing that tool bag of
every genre because because the MTV
generation and especially now the way
streaming is you know what I'm saying
because back in you know when you had to
like seek out your music you know I'm
saying you had to go to the record store
and seek out your whatever kind of music
your taste you know preferred it was a
little different you know what I'm
saying but then when MTV started playing
everything they'd have those box I don't
know if you remember that they have like
the blocks they have hip hop A hip-hop
block a rock block R B Block yeah yeah
you know what I'm saying and like so if
you're just sitting there watching MTV
which during the summer time you know
that's just what we did as kids you were
gonna see that NWA video you were gonna
see that you know uh Will Smith
Summertime video and then you were going
to see Nirvana you know what I'm saying
and then you might even see some Tim
McGraw and some you know whatever like
so this generate that generation and
moving forward everybody was just
everything was just that accessible you
know what I'm saying so everybody has
been touched by every genre of music in
some kind of way yeah yeah and now you
start to see and this is interesting too
you see a lot of black country guys on
Tick Tock I see a lot of and yeah
there's a lot it's getting kind of wild
dude like I'll meet like everything is
just a lot more mixed I've always had
this theory that it's gonna like
in three generations everybody going to
be beige yeah you know I say that same
thing man we all started the same color
I believe you know I mean look I wasn't
there I can't personally well what color
is a zygote or whatever like a baby well
I just think that they're in that part
of the world that particular part of the
world where the the world was allegedly
based on what we've been told born you
know
um people look a certain way and then I
think as we migrated to different areas
you know what I'm saying like our
ancestors migrated to this cold place up
here and then had to be in caves for six
months out of the year and and you know
saying so over thousands of years of
that reduced exposure to the sun yeah
the skin just got paler so we split up
but then now in the last what 100 200
years everybody's come back together so
yeah it's just a matter of time for it
we go back to that same color you know
which is yeah you didn't even be able to
find anybody to hate man at that point
yeah you're gonna need a chart if you
want to be racist dude that's why I like
because some places you can't just be
racist people still gonna hate
themselves though because ultimately
honestly I can't hate anybody else
unless I hate myself yeah and I can't
love anybody else unless I love myself
man you know let's just
um so what was so when you're you you're
so you get so get me to the point where
you kind of your music really takes off
so basically I I uh moved up to Athens
where Big Steve was at and uh met Bobby
stamps who's my manager for 20 years and
uh introduced me to a guy introduced me
to Colt Ford into a guy named Shannon
houchins who owns a label and him and
Colt have a label here in town called
Average Joe's Entertainment in Nashville
and um
but I started just
it was a roundabout way but
I started just really finding myself in
the studio you know because I I was you
know I'm saying the first time I ever
went to a studio I was working as a as
an electrician's Apprentice running a
conduit bending pipe and uh and I saved
up like 350 over one Summer and the only
other guy that I could find that was a
rap you know I'm saying that even any
inkling of like wanting to be a rapper
oh Rodney was his name he was he was he
was a different kind of guy you know
what I'm saying but uh and what you mean
autism or something no he was just he
was just a different type of cat I don't
I don't really know how to put it you
know he he didn't come from like uh he
didn't everybody played Sports you know
what I'm saying that was like your
biggest badge of honor you could have
and he wasn't that kind of guy he was he
was really like a
kind of like an Eminem type like when
you hear Eminem talk about like the way
he grew up you know what I'm saying like
kind of like that kind of deal you know
like in the trailer like the little
small mobile home you know what I'm
saying and and uh they'd never seen it
before like him huh yeah well I mean
I wouldn't say that it was even that
rare but it just wasn't most people
he was just kind of like the kind of
person that was just was invisible he
was redheaded yes he was dude and he
liked Black Culture yes bruh tell me
this bro tell him you just blew my mind
with that the first dude the first the
guy the guy that was always wearing a
North Carolina jersey and hanging out
with black people was always a
red-headed dude bro
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't even tell me it wasn't bro man
every I don't know how it worked out bro
I don't know how the Sun hit him or
whatever but but I kind of I think our
generation at least where I was growing
up like we kind of were the first
generation to like just we all kicked it
you know what I'm saying because
football was the most important thing
and everybody you know and like if you
play football like we all the colors
that matters is Navy you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah and so um you know but
but as far as the story of finishing we
saved up we went to the studio we get to
the studio up in Atlanta it was called
eight ball recording studios I never
forget so I had my 300 he had his 300 we
got like a 12 hour block they're all
Italian damn boy does that mean
producers are in there no no no no no
listen so then we get in there and he's
like all right where's y'all's beats and
we're like huh it hadn't even occurred
to us that we were gonna need beats and
so basically so we don't you know saved
up all this money over a period of
months sure that's a lot of money at
that point and he's kind of represented
to me like man I know what to do I know
what to do but we get there and we ain't
got no beats we don't know how to make
no beats but the guy was actually cool
enough to sit there and kind of like
allow us to like he basically made some
garbage beat but you know like held our
hands there when we felt like we were
doing it or something and we recorded
two songs one was called Nothing But
game Theo oh it ain't nothing but game
coming out my mouth player player it was
like the rap was like right quick I'm
bringing tight [ __ ] for these jealous
marks to jock Belling through the
parking lot when my partner sparked the
chop now I'm feeling kind of strange
like my state of mind didn't change off
that hurricane and think I'm starting to
think that I'm deranged type [ __ ] you
know what I mean yeah that's how to make
you feel good though oh man it was the
it was terrible man like it really was
but I was so proud yeah I mean I had
something recorded on a cassette table
we could ride around listen to it I can
feel it right now
but the people when I got to ask them oh
it was just that it wasn't that good but
nothing good it was that one uh oscar
but
um basically like I just felt like
this is it like I'm I felt like I had
already made it basically you know what
I'm saying even though I'm still working
three jobs I'm selling mid-grade weed
like but I'm like dang man like this is
it you know what I'm saying like girls
come around yeah I'm a rapper what do
you mean oh I'll tell you my song you
know what I'm saying you got a business
card now oh man don't let me like steal
like a a laminate from like a tour or
something like so so dead because
fashion the producer that I ended up
working with in Athens and and all those
guys Bobby and Colt were close to
Jermaine Dupri they worked with Jermaine
Dupree and they had like all these stuff
jackets and stuff that said so so deaf
on it so anytime I could like I would
try to get that jacket for a night and
go just post stuff oh this whole thing
what do you mean and so um just flexing
you know what I mean it's like feeling
like I kind of like manifested certain
things by like I would tell girls you
know the dungeon family is a big a very
important
um
um what's the word I mean a musical
family in Atlanta that consists of
outcast Goody Mob like a dynasty or
something I mean just the just the
forefathers they're the pillars of you
know in my view of of hip-hop in Atlanta
um as far as representing Atlanta for
real for real
um in a in an accurate way
um but
I used to tell girls that I was the the
white member of the dungeon family
like five years before accounting or
whatever no like no I was the white
rapper yeah like in in like there was it
was said
um and I think it probably was said by
Rico from organized noise he was kind of
the
the um
the dungeon was his mother's basement
you know what I'm saying his mother's
house so he was kind of the patriarch is
that a good way to put it yeah the
Airbnb owner yeah for sure and um and so
I'd heard he said white folks shouldn't
be participating in hip-hop or something
like that but I was always like well he
gonna love me he gonna love me because
I'm I'm for real like I'm real with my
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying I'm I'm
representing who I am you know and some
Georgia [ __ ] the right way he gonna love
me watch this that's what I would tell
like my friends but I would tell girls
that yeah I'm I'm in the dungeon family
what do you mean like way before I could
it could have even been anything
remotely you know resembling reality and
I'd be damned if I ain't become a white
boy in the dungeon family
yeah you know what I'm saying so that's
I guess that's what I get from fake it
till you make it you know what I mean
and um and you know me and Rico that's
my brother you know what I'm saying the
guy that allegedly has said that I mean
he's he's as close to anybody to me as
anybody I've met in the music business
period so
man it's just crazy how life can unfold
you know if you but I but I had so much
Faith back then man really so you had
faith in you meaning God you mean I mean
God but in but in God's plan for me
um just in that God had a plan for me
you know I'm saying uh to to do
something that was going to impact the
world and that you know that I I just
always felt like I had a spirit man that
that you know I I want to
be an extension of whatever that that
ultimate loves you know love based
energy or spirited that God is yeah you
know what I'm saying I always just felt
like an extension of that because you
know I like to to be a purveyor of of
love and light so to speak you know so
and I just felt like there was some plan
where I was going like just have an
impact on the world in some kind of way
you know based on that and um you know
in some ways it's worked out exactly how
I could have drawn it up and then in
some ways not you know what I'm saying
but it's been a hell of a journey you
know I'm saying that and I still do not
for one second question God's you know
like involvement in the whole thing yes
that's just me you know what I'm saying
people can are welcome to believe
anything they want you know in all of
our experiences and our our uh
upbringing you know in our experiences
as adults everything shapes us you know
what I'm saying our DNA you know is a
part of that too but I just um
I just believe what I could what I
believe and it's something that I that I
feel and it can't be Quantified in words
or you know it's just beyond us but I
know
when I'm being creative Theo like when
I'm writing when I really get in that
zone there's nothing I can ever do to
feel closer to God or you know to
to just that that energy source that
love you know what I'm saying like I
just feel it it's like I'm in such
Harmony in the way time can just
disappear it's like I'm doing what I was
put here to do you know what I'm saying
and and whatever
whoever created me is pleased at this
time you know what I'm saying and it's
like I feel some uh like internal
um turmoil at times too and it's like
I'm not I'm not uh doing what I was put
here to do and and uh that that spear is
not pleased yeah I said I can feel that
too
not abandoned though you know just right
do you um where were we at with it man I
I got a terrible terrible like um
this is like the third podcast I've done
and uh Landing things yeah I'm saying
it's like I I love talking about every
aspect of my story but I'm definitely
trying to work on Landing [ __ ] there's a
couple times we were like well let's
finish this point before we go on to
something else because I I sometimes
kind of forget what's I don't forget
what's going on but it's hard for me to
like uh remember and be thinking at the
same time no [ __ ]
um well put so but to go back to the so
at the studio you know what I'm saying
so we get that that song Done Right you
want some [ __ ] boy are in there yeah
yeah and he was because look dude I'm
telling you this the first time they had
a white dude that wanted to be black in
our area bro they've never seen it
before they put him in special ed bro
wow you hear that man that's crazy they
put him in special [ __ ] head bruh
shout out Brian Purvis dog praise God BP
what oh he's still he just got locked up
for something bring him up free that man
free BP
yeah that's true I had social studies
with him and he [ __ ] he was he not
been on a hell of a journey though oh
like this dude he's been through it all
he took those bullets you know what I'm
saying yeah he really something happened
to him yeah uh pu yeah there you go
bring him up guys
we do attempted murder that's
hypothetical yeah attempt it you know we
ain't paying four dollars to find out
that's it happy Hanukkah yeah that's all
we got for you bro but uh stay well baby
yeah man but they put him in there dog
can't be good be good at it they put him
in there man damn
but you knew him pretty well y'all was
y'all cool we were cool for a while he
was hard to really get close to man he
just said
he had that [ __ ] rattle in him bro
you could tell he never slept damn he
probably hit his no drugs no drug oh bro
he had drugs built and I think we know
that now as mental illness you know what
I'm saying like oh yeah but back then it
was just damn yeah
he was early he was just he looked like
he [ __ ] was early and late at the
same time bro
he would just you know his eyes never
shut he looked like he didn't sleep man
he made he knows what he went through
who knows what his whole life was like
they made it well he was I'm sure when
he stayed that word you know what I'm
saying like I always thought this is
something I think about now and I'm sure
you got some insight and a perspective
on this too
what if we went back through history
Theo and looked at every violent crime
every murder every even rape that's ever
been committed in the history of planet
Earth
going back
I wonder what percentage of those
violent crimes were committed by people
that had they had I think you know a
thorough psychiatric evaluation
or mentally it was a mental illness you
know what I'm saying it was something
that you know at the time just obviously
there was no
there was nothing winning the mental
illness mental health even become a
thing like last 50 years yeah and it's
even been like a like a slow and you
know Jagged like Ascent to where we are
now which but but I'm just I thought
about that like if we you know there's
there's just something to be said for
that though that like hurt people hurt
people 100 man well they just had a guy
on Joe Rogan this guy gabber mate gabber
mate and he is like uh
um I want to say he's a psychiatrist but
he's like a really good thinker some
people are real good at thinking
and he talks a lot about trauma and
trauma's kind of a buzzword that people
use a lot now but one thing that that he
was saying resonates yeah yeah yeah that
really resonates yeah yeah that really
impresses
yeah that [ __ ] resonates bro raising
Nets bro you're so close raising eights
um
but he was saying how like TR like that
like pain and stuff can be transferred
through DNA and I maybe some of that's
believable or not but it can definitely
be transferred through the way that you
treat people and the the new things that
I like the way that you it's so crazy
how many times something happens to
somebody when they're a child and then
the same they do the exact same thing
they do the exact same thing and it's
interesting man it is and it's just a
lot of like uh we're just now getting to
the point too where we have so much
reflection of ourselves because of uh
that's a good and bad thing right it's a
good and bad thing but it's like we have
such a recording of how people operate
and behave now that you're able to see a
lot of like okay and compare it you know
right
um and just document it so I think it's
like we're getting to a point where it's
like we're really documenting how much
pain has been like just in the
in the damn gene pool of humanity
and uh and it makes you wonder kind of
what the future will be like will we
will we be able to solve that kind of
thing or we will just be able to
continue to just because I don't think
we we are more aware of like of just you
know mental illnesses and but I don't
necessarily think that we've really
figured out the best ways to treat them
yeah you know what I'm saying to to give
somebody you know because it's like
you know I've been on um on meds before
you know at different times and and uh
it's like okay I don't feel that way
anymore but now I feel this way which is
equally terrible or it affects you know
some other aspect of my being that just
makes it either worse for me ultimately
or at best like just a trade-off you
know what I'm saying so
um you know I just treating everything
with with chemical with man-made
medicine you know right it might not be
the way yeah it might not be you know we
might look in in 30 years you might look
back like okay we took a real bad turn
as a society like back in the late 1800s
when they were like drilling you know
screws in people's you know in the at
your temples and they were like just
kill that frontal lobe that's how it
would make people like chill out yeah
that was 125 years ago I think you had
to pay for that dude to come over yeah
and your family's there like how did
that work literally you're just like
you're just like
for like 60 years like it's crazy man
like they like who came up with that
like they should have done I hope that
that was what that person at some point
in their life I hope whoever thought of
that first and started doing that I hope
they had to experience it
man that's crazy um and they were also
saying on that episode just about how
people take care of their children and
stuff like that like it um just that
there's not enough connection between
families and stuff these days people
used to be in tribes a lot of that has
been talked about in the past 10 years
about how people used to be in tribes
and we were closer so not only did your
mother see you but your aunt saw you
your grandmother was right there there
was constant like
um attention and evaluation of what was
going on with you in that uh that they
think people developed the healthier
then I don't know if that's true but
it's just like a it was a theory that
that man was talking about you know I
just I think that this the gap between
human beings period is just getting
water iron wire that is weird you know
what I mean and we were talking about it
last night like social media you know
it's designed to bring us all closer
together but ultimately it creates such
polarized you know like views of things
you know I'm saying like
social media is probably as much to
blame as anything for
the way our country has it's always been
these two uh drastically different
choices that we had when it came to
political stuff you know what I'm saying
and and I just won't save the record
[ __ ] both of them but
um but it's like because that's just not
that just doesn't make good sense to me
like our two choices are these two
radically different like like viewpoints
and it's just crazy but like social
media has driven
that wedge it just made it that much
wider that Gap you know what I'm saying
yeah it's it definitely led to people
don't seek information they seek
affirmation you know what I'm saying so
they follow things that they know are
going to continue to feed them the same
thing they've been on you know I'm
saying and sometimes I think each side
is right you know at different times I
think the sensible compromise of the
middle is kind of that just makes a
little too much sense to me you know I'm
saying like sometimes you know this way
of thinking is going to be the best way
to go about it and then sometimes this
way I think it's going to be the best
way to go about it but you know you'll
have like these 280 character or less
like
um you know just
what do you call it hot takes basically
like of just saying something or
reporting a certain event in a certain
way that's going to reaffirm to that
group of people that yep see right you
know what I'm saying yes that's it
exactly and so and then they
it's like the um whole the old adage um
a locking will travel around the world
before the truth has a chance to put his
pants on or whatever I butchered it but
yeah something like that but I
understand it yeah yeah people share
stuff you know I'm saying the next thing
you know it's just it spreads so like we
used to play that game the telephone
game remember when you was kid we'd play
the telephone game oh you're like sit
there and Whisper and tell this person
and this person anybody can time it got
to the end it was somebody lied oh we
had one kid bro this is kind of [ __ ]
up but he would just yell the it when it
came back to him he would just say was
the n-word every time bro
this [ __ ] yeah he was just I
don't even think he was I think he was
just mentally unwell you know but yeah
it was funny it was oh no something's
wrong with him oh but he uh it would be
like hurricane and it would break around
and every time and the teacher would
[ __ ] but he just knew that word man
he knew it like got a reaction probably
yeah he might have had up he didn't
understand it but like he might he also
talked about like Egypt and the Pharaohs
a lot he might have had um
mental disability right but um so take
me through so you so the music is
popping things get going I apologize I
like to talk about a variety of [ __ ]
this is what it is this is I don't want
to de-emphasize you know the fact that
that I've had an incredible journey you
know through music but um so yeah so
then I'm in Athens at that point I'm
starting to make some connections and we
ended up putting out
um my first album my first major release
on B Club Timberland's record label with
the first thing the single ugly was on
this album
um we put we put out an independent
version of that album by the same name
about two years before the major label
version came so that's what people
started hearing yeah it started
spreading around Georgia and it was like
people always talk about marketing plans
you know what I'm saying and like like
we got to come up with the perfect no
when something's the [ __ ] [ __ ] it's just
word of mouth is the marketing plan and
it was that kind of deal you know and
I'm just blessed to have been a part of
it and to you you know to have had that
Clarity at that particular point in time
to be able to do something that people
[ __ ] with to that degree but literally
like one person two people two people
four people four people eight people and
so on and so on and so on and yeah so
pretty soon and it was there was a lot
of other like you know um
uh
interesting details tidbits of
information to the story but short story
long
um basically we signed with Interscope
Records you know Jimmy Iovine the same
after in 1999 when I first saw hi my
name is I was
destroyed why cause you thought he'd
beat you to the punch I thought I
thought at that time as a white rapper
you pretty much felt like ain't gonna be
with one more like if they ever if if
one ever gets back in the door it's just
gonna be one and then it's like I saw
that and I was like
he did it perfect you know what I'm
saying and I remember my best friend Big
Steve and I was just all depressed and
he came and he was like
man I think you got it [ __ ] up man
he's like yeah he's that's some awesome
[ __ ] he said but you Southern you is
it's different you know what I'm saying
like you you still straight you know I'm
saying you still got your lane
I was like Keep It Coming keep it coming
all right you know what I'm saying and
then I got back up you know eventually
and got back to work and two years later
I was signed to the same label as Eminem
yeah did you ever get to meet him yeah
yeah I did
um I met him at the uh anger management
tour in 2003 it's a crazy experience I
think it's anger management meetings
that's what I thought you guys
you know he was uh
I don't know he was he was a little
he was on the private plane like level
you know what I'm saying when I was yeah
when I was still flying commercial you
know or I'm still flying commercial but
I was definitely get on up there in
first class and all that but you know he
he jumped very quickly to private plane
level you know what I'm saying where he
was just moving at his own pace but but
um we met man and he he was he was very
complimentary you know I'm saying it was
probably the only time I've ever been
Starstruck in my life when I'm when I
met Eminem it was just like wow that's
really it that's the real Eminem right
there you know what I'm saying and uh
but man he was extremely complimentary
you know I mean and he always has been
um even when uh there was a diss song
where he dissed me and Paul Paul Wall
that leaked and even in the discs
he was kind of I feel like he was
complimentary of me you know what I'm
saying like he was and he was actually I
don't know where the information that he
uh but it was it was wrong the wrong
drug he said I was on or whatever you
know what I'm saying well yeah I hate
that when people get your drugs yeah man
it's like come on man like he who is
without sin cast the first stone you
know but
um it is what it is you know Paul
Rosenberg his manager was always uh
super cool to me and the whole Shady
record staff I never have had a chance
to get close to Eminem like that as far
as building like a super you know close
personal relationship but
may I he would ask people about me you
know what I'm saying anytime he would
see somebody that like he knew [ __ ]
with me he would be like how's bubba
doing you know what I'm saying like
right a couple times
so you know I I got another respect for
him man love and respect
um and uh so but to going back so I was
signed the Interscope Records for about
nine months and after having so much
success Jimmy Iovine shout out to Jimmy
Iovine just an absolute iconic figure in
music and yeah and entertainment period
and uh that man believed in me a great
deal
um I still don't even necessarily
understand what you know what it was
about me that made him believe in me so
much
um but he did you know I'm saying he's
he's a genius you know type of type of
human being so that always gave me
confidence just to know that like man
the baddest [ __ ] in this this
whole business I saw something in me
yeah like he believes in me to the point
where he's going to push the maxim the
biggest button that Interscope Records
the number one label in music you know
could push you know I'm saying six
million dollars spent on me in marketing
people know the name Bubba Sparks you
know what I'm saying and um and so but
he after the Eminem and Drake success he
kind of was like I might be onto
something with this whole get you know
the Black producer white boy give him
credibility you know off top and so he
tried a couple other routes you know
what I'm saying as far as hooking me up
with people and it was
the chemistry just wasn't there and then
and then finally he he asked me one
night he called me and he was like I'm
about to meet with Timberland he's like
what do you think about that I was like
oh I'd be perfect dude I was like that's
it you know what I'm saying that's it
next morning I was on a flight out to
L.A and the rest was history and I was
the first artist uh released that
Timberland as far as
it being his record label and him
releasing the artist yeah yeah it was
the first one I was the first artist he
ever the first one yeah overall right
yes sir and so what was your personal
life like at that point because life
gets crazy bro when you start getting
where I was a young country [ __ ]
with
millions of dollars and pretty much
whatever you could have in a uh a
budding a spawning drug addict and you
know what I'm saying and and just a kid
man that that just you know I I just
loved life at that time though you know
what I'm saying we were just were you
happy Marie stoked at that time man on
that first album you damn right I was
yeah you know I was really happy man I
was going to London and just damn man
everything was so like you know
performing on Saturday Night Live man
you know I'm saying Derek Jeter's the
host you know saying me and Shakira are
the musical guest you know it and I'm
I'm in the green room before I perform
on Saturday Night Live and they knock on
the doors about 15 minutes before going
they're like
um Mr Sparks um there are two guests
here that would just like to say hello
if if you um if they're interrupting
you're disturbing you it's fine they can
come back later but if they could just
say hello it's Chris Rock and Jamie Foxx
nah you know what I'm saying so I'm just
kicking it like you know I'm just like
cut your ass boy you know what I'm
saying like I'm just like what's up man
you know I don't know no other way to be
you know what I'm saying it's like and
like I said I didn't have a reference
point of another example of of somebody
like me you know to show me how to act a
different way other than just being me
like I just and it's like sometimes it's
just because I for lack of a uh
understanding of any other way I could
possibly act or be I would just [ __ ] it
I'm just gonna be me again I'm gonna
keep being mean keep being me yeah well
sometimes it it was [ __ ] up but well
there's a lot of parts inside of you
obviously no doubt
um
so those are so that's really the highs
man yeah did y'all perform on VMAs and
stuff like that I never performed on the
VMAs I um like um I went to several VMAs
like did you go to the one with NSYNC at
it when Eminem came out with all the
different things
I came to into the game the year after
that one yeah I'll tell you when I came
into the game I was sitting right here
at my first VMAs when Alicia Keys was at
the VMAs playing Fallen beautiful
falling on the uh on the piano
and I remember just being like
I Can't Help Falling yeah oh where's you
oh man dude I was just like I'm here I'm
in this [ __ ] yeah dude I remember I
said it was right after Chris Farley
died I sat behind his brothers and I
said my God yes I did man Chris farted
that was my guy I said by Shawshank
Redemption the guy the prisoner
like Tim Robbins Tim Robbins yeah what
was his name in the movie Christopher
now that's Christopher Robbins I'm
thinking of I don't know bro that's a
great movie though that was crazy and I
fell asleep when Instinct was performing
bro I [ __ ] fell asleep in my seat bro
but Nelly came by and he [ __ ] dabbed
me up when he came by though
the high like this this is the craziest
bro afterwards I got invited to a
threesome with these ladies and one of
them gave me some cocaine and I got all
[ __ ] scared because I never done this
is the story you told on uh on uh it was
Joe Rogan or something I watched what
you were talking about like the time you
were like in New York now you were
supposed to do something the next
morning oh that was with Daryl
Strawberry yes you were interviewing
Daryl strawberry damn that was a tough
night well just I know that feeling the
fun part is fun but the on fun part
ain't the Inside Out feeling and just
knowing that you're functioning at about
36 oh I get so much anxiety but I was at
this threesome but I wanted to remember
it so they had a bag of little sex toys
in there so I caught one of them on the
way out right I snuck one
and I put it in like my belt kind of you
know so then I was in New York City I
went to like a little key Bodega to get
a some snack or something a little uh
coconut water they had just come out
with coconut water and I tried it and uh
and a little I think I got a little
thing of donuts or something but while I
was in there the little sex toy thing
fell out on the floor in there bro and
dude it was like a migrant family
bro it was a Vietnamese family owned it
or something you know and they had a
little kid in there bro and he [ __ ]
brought it over to me he didn't know
what it was he just thought it was a toy
oh and I just it was a toy but it was it
just broke my the whole [ __ ] was just
bad but anyway man
um so when so so you and I talked to
like about like when do you start to
realize that you feel like you had like
a some addiction I was well you know I
pretty much just kind of like partied
you know what I'm saying it's like then
I was in a snowmobile accident ice
fishing in Canada it was like you know
real [ __ ] up and I got prescribed like
uh I mean I had dabbled with like you
know popping a Lortab or something you
know not to mention specific drugs but
you know what I'm saying no it's fine I
took some Somas one time
and I drove into a driveway and there
wasn't a driveway hey if someone's ain't
no joke boy Flexeril in summer dude and
my buddy this gay fella R.I.P Billy
conforto he was like one of the first
gay prize fighters in America what is
this
this is Celsius something pretty good
see what this thing hitting though
um
and I thought I don't know if you try to
take advantage of me or what whatever
anyway bro but what uh yeah so when do
you start to know that you had a issue
um
I was on tour with uh blink 182.
shout out what trap Travis Parker and um
I had been prescribed Percocets for
about six months and uh then they just
cut them cold turkey and I knew nothing
about addiction or you know or
uh physical dependence or withdrawals
dope scene I knew nothing about [ __ ]
then um [ __ ] about [ __ ] I knew [ __ ]
about [ __ ]
um and I had run out and I just think
I'm just done with that you know what
I'm saying and I remember I had this uh
this uh process you know I'm saying I
would the bus would get into wherever we
were going like that morning and I would
go to the hotel and I would sleep till
like three o'clock I would get up slowly
you know I'm saying I take a shower and
stuff and then before I would leave the
hotel at like five o'clock I would take
like I think I would take two
pills and then like four shots of Patron
and that would get me like in the go be
me in public and you know start angling
towards Showtime you know and I remember
I didn't obviously didn't have the pills
and I laid down
trying to go to sleep like normal 30
minutes later I wake up sweating just
like feeling inside out I'm like oh [ __ ]
I'm sick this is crazy like like I think
I'm just sick like cold or flu or
something
and I'm like oh man and I try to lay
back down maybe take some cold medicine
lay back down can't can't sleep but I'm
like man what is wrong is unique feeling
this is like a I've never felt this
exact type of thing before
and then it hit me
damn it's because I ain't got no pills
damn am I addicted to these things like
what
and I remember I talked to somebody like
probably my manager or somebody and was
like
you think I'm addicted to him he's like
I don't know maybe so you know so were
you taking more of them than you were
supposed to and I was like
yeah
of course
but I was just like you know I don't
I don't know I just it was just a
foreign concept to me you know it's just
that was definitely one of those things
like I had known some some addicts you
know I'm saying
some drunks a lot of drunks you know
what I'm saying but that's all they used
to call them really yeah right and um
but for me I just never nobody ever
thinks it's gonna it could happen to
them until it does but I just remember
being like damn I'm addicted to these
[ __ ] but I was moving so fast I
said you know when I get to a stopping
point you know resting like area I'll
take care of and get on off of them but
for now I just need to buy them on the
street you know so I started buying them
on the street real heavy my what tray
chunky tray shout out to chunky trades
like seven years sober now or some [ __ ]
gang gang big Steve's uh 15 years sober
right now you know I'm only uh dip [ __ ]
that just hadn't been able to you know
find that willingness or whatever like
to you know I'm a thinker you know what
I'm saying that could be that could be a
big [ __ ] uh hindrance to to recovery
when you're creative you create a lot of
ways by yourself buddy that's a shame I
gotta I just got like I think I'm like
one maybe 150 days maybe yeah I remember
talking to you uh we were both like at
the same time we're on this it's to the
same journey I don't know if I'll have
you know these days forever we'll see
um but um just to so people so you
started having to get them like behind
the scenes yeah so I was buying them on
the street and uh
story long that was like in 2004 I think
and um and then I ended up finally going
to rehab like pretty much at the peak of
miss new booty you know what I'm saying
of that I did not enjoy that you know
you're asking did I enjoy the the when I
first came into the game The Ugly
uh well ugly was my first number first
ever release as far as a single and my
first number one record and um and that
was a great time but the miss new booty
time man
it was just
trying to be in places traveling around
running out of pills just having to
White Knuckle it be tough you know what
I'm saying I can get through you know
just big [ __ ] you know what I mean and
things that I should have
you know I should have been enjoying you
know I'm saying it was a huge record you
know and just so many blessings came
from it you know but my my uh perception
at that time was was really [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying but I remember I
had like half a million dollars worth of
shows
um over like a two-month period
and I told my manager Bobby I was like
man I gotta go you know what I'm saying
I said uh I can't do it anymore man I
said I'm about to get on about to check
out of here or something I don't know
what's
and um like how was it did it get pretty
like because I've had
like I've had some times I probably went
to some strange you know I've been in
some strange places you know what it was
for me getting chunked by people like
meaning like I got the number one song
in the world at this time and these
[ __ ] got me sitting at this
bowling alley for six hours yeah and it
just I couldn't take it anymore you know
what I'm saying it's just like man I
can't be a punk ass [ __ ] for so
long you know what I'm saying like
that's just the way I'm the way my
account is set up oh I want to do it
that's hilarious way my kind of set up I
want to do what I want to do man that's
all I've always been that way because
you always know that somebody that they
on the phone laughing to their homeboys
talking about man I got but bubbles but
man I got him sitting up here at this
bowling alley man this [ __ ] crazy you
know that kind of [ __ ] and I'm just like
you mean waiting for drug yeah I'm just
sitting there like they're like give me
the money and then they they gonna ride
UPS whatever and I'm sitting there for
six hours on a Saturday and probably
missing some [ __ ] that I'm supposed to
be you know what I mean and just just I
you know I just couldn't
I I couldn't do it anymore you know what
I'm saying and then just tired of being
dope sick man like
you know that was that was the deal at
that time you know what I'm saying was
the opiates you know what I'm saying and
you know I
[Music]
I don't go down the same street you know
what I'm saying like like um multiple
times very often you know what I'm
saying as far as that goes but I I would
have never at that time I could have
never seen there being a day a six hour
period where I didn't use like some type
of opiate at that time and I thought I
would never be able to get beyond that
you know and I and I did you know
Suboxone is a part of my journey you
know what I'm saying I can say that's
the only way I was able to to stop and
uh and stay stopped as far as and people
say like you just traded one addiction
for another yes and no because the
difference is if I'm out here taking uh
Rock season Oxycontin and whatever else
especially this fentanyl world it's it's
this uh this going down out here now
that's that's a whole different level
but
um but
when you take suboxone you can take four
milligrams a day this is just my
experience now you know I'm saying I'm
not the judge jury an executioner on on
anything you know I'm saying my opinion
in 250 I get your Coca-Cola
but man you sound like Riff Raff bro
y'all got some of the same thing man
it's real interesting yeah you know I
never met Riff Raff man but I I know I
know it's just certain people you just
know you [ __ ] with them you know what
I'm saying special guy man he's cool
he's real creative too no man this [ __ ]
he did with the tennis rack at that time
man some of the most unbelievable [ __ ]
I've ever seen man he's a deep dude and
we've got a several Mutual you know but
anyway so um but you know your tolerance
doesn't go up on the Suboxone you can
take the same amount and it's never
gonna your tolerance is never gonna like
you know force you to take more where
whereas you know when when you're taking
the other stuff like your tolerance is
just gonna slowly build I've always
wanted to do methadone I've never done
it yeah I I've taken some methadone but
not as like a solution but just as a
that's all you got but
um um but yeah so and uh but did you
think so a lot of times like I I've been
in and out of the program for maybe six
years right six years I've been in and
out since 2007 so what's that 15. and I
never thought I had this problem I
thought everything was pretty normal in
my life you know and it came on really
later in my you know I thought for me
but when people came in with opiate
addiction
I always thought to me it seemed like
you had people that were real alcoholics
that were in there but then some people
just got so like somebody goes in
because they hurt their back that's not
a person that's
and then they get I mean people were
getting so addicted but your mind
doesn't know the difference it's the
thing you know what I'm saying like if
it's just like I know people with my old
sponsor shout out to Stephen came down
on the grains but he uh
he was like I ain't taking nothing he
said I don't care what happens to me I
ain't taking no pain medication he said
because my brain is not gonna know the
difference you know I'm saying that [ __ ]
gets in my system it's gonna do what it
does you know I'm saying regardless of
the reason being righteous or you know
it being prescribed by a doctor or
anything like that you know what I'm
saying they feel like they made a cheat
code when they made uh opiate stuff when
they made like some of these opiates it
feels like the these companies I mean
it's like they
made so many more people addicts that
were oh man you can't tell me it was and
I you know I could break it down even
even on a More freakier Level man it's
just like it's very interesting to me
that
2000 up to say 2008 they were pain pills
everywhere and you could you could
there's about three or four cities in
America you could get heroin in
port cities type stuff like you know uh
New York La uh maybe Baltimore New
Orleans you know what I'm saying like
you just couldn't get heroin a lot of
places you know what I'm saying
um and I would know you know especially
like anything that was actually anywhere
close to resembling actual real heroin
and um and then I don't know we go fight
a war you know what I'm saying in the
golden try or where the poppy feels the
most popular fields are in the whole
world
and I'm not saying that's the only
reason that that war took place or
there's a primary reason but but here
fast forward to now
hell it's damn difficult to get a pain
pill you know what I'm saying like a lot
of um you know uh
parents of of you know uh kids that had
overdosed and died started going to
Congress
you know started basically letting their
presence be felt letting their you know
feelings be felt you know and voicing
you know their angst and
and sorrow you know and I think some
pressure was applied you know what I'm
saying for the As far as the pain pills
to to tighten up on that
but then now
Here Comes This fentanyl [ __ ] but even
before that I mean
they got selling heroin in Huntsville
Alabama you know what I'm saying like
it's this shit's all over the place but
the the the pills were cleaned up to a
large measure you know what I'm saying
but
um yeah this is interesting you know
what I'm saying I mean you know I
wouldn't be shot if our government is
selling our own drugs to it I wouldn't
or somebody is something it may not who
knows who it could be like you know it
could be some corporation that just has
that much pool and you know they just
you know funded this one campaign of
this one person who has the influence
who knows you know what I'm saying like
I'm like I said I just I can only
speculate because they damn sure don't
invite me to the meetings yeah or
whatever kind of [ __ ] I don't even need
any email
yeah for real you know and um and so I
don't know but those things with Arsenio
Hall used to say things to make it go
hmm I got to go on his show one time
that was a real highlight for me that
would have been when this show came back
on that was the first show I ever got to
do stand-up comedy on was Arsenio senio
man that was so epic when I was young
dude it was huge man and then In Living
Color bruh yeah Living Color
you know I used to watch Johnny Carson
too I actually remember watching Johnny
Carson wow you know that was and I
remember when he when Jay Leno took over
for me and I actually ended up doing the
Jay Leno show wow yeah and Jay Leno used
to do the Cool Ranch Dorito commercials
but um yeah man David Letterman did
David manners what a blessed journey man
yeah you've got to have so many uh
unique experiences especially for you
know somebody from not bad for a farmer
with a pitch for it not bad at all man
um you know my old high school football
coach used to say
guys you don't have to take a back seat
to anybody rest in peace Jim Holly you
know and that's something that just
stuck with me through life you know what
I'm saying anytime I feel overwhelmed or
feel like I'm not worthy of this no no
you don't have to take a back seat to
anybody you know what I'm saying
anything or anybody
you know you you know saying you worked
hard to get here just like everybody
else you know what I'm saying like let's
say you put your socks on one leg at a
time just like everybody else I take
shits they take shits I fart they fart
you know
you know I like chalupas they may or may
not they may or may not yeah sometimes I
think my thing I struggle with sometimes
I mean I struggle with a lot of stuff
but I really struggle with that thing
like uh
making uh
like what other people think of me yeah
you know that's always been really hard
I think it kind of says that they don't
it's either just not cursed with any
self-awareness and some people are just
like that sometimes the biggest stars
just they don't have self-awareness they
don't right so they're not even thinking
about them but how do they hire people
perceiving them you know what I'm saying
it's like it'll be a blessing yeah and
it would be a curse and a blessing you
know I'm saying that's just the way it
is with everything but but yeah I wish
that didn't
um
because here's what I wish I had a
little bit more of my own I wish I'd had
a bit more somebody helping me build my
own self-worth when I was young so I had
a little bit more it just wasn't a part
of the culture of growing up you know
like yeah but some people got it because
they're you know somebody told that I
just feel like some people got it I'm
not like having a pity party no honestly
I just wish that I had a little more and
it's it's tragic that you don't have
kids you know what I'm saying it's
tragic that I don't have I know a lot of
and that's what we talk about like that
that gap between males and females that
keeps getting wider and wider you know
what I mean like in the way that we
connect with one another just what's
your cash out you know like you know
what I'm saying like it's gotten a lot
more like just out front transactional
it seems like you know what I'm saying
and so I don't
since I got divorced in 2019 I haven't
seriously dated anybody because I don't
know how to [ __ ] date in this world
but that's a whole other story but but
you know like we're over 40 you know
what I'm saying and so like bro I mean
like I just know you gotta get a [ __ ]
kid bro I know a lot of Real Deal men
that need to have kids you know what I'm
saying because I would like to know what
a child with my stuff
and I love my parents man this isn't no
they they did the best they could with
with what they were equipped with you
know I'm saying what they've been given
and they did a great job because you
know I've done a lot of things and
they're a part of that you know what I'm
saying and and they love me you know but
as far as just like
believing in a in a child and like
giving him the freedom to really like
Express himself and encouraging him that
you know what I mean like and still
being stern you know I'm saying and
being a disciplinarian but but just you
know not discouraging dreams and you
know I'm saying like and they were just
trying to protect me oh you know what
I'm saying about discouraging Dreams by
saying you you know that's just that's
just sealing foolishness you know what
I'm saying like you you need to you know
have a different plan you know so you
need to have a practical plan one is
realistic you know what I'm saying
they're just trying to you know but I
know now that all that's [ __ ] that's
programming you know what I'm saying
that's fear-based programming you know
and we can we can do a lot in this world
you know you know what your evidence of
it and so I would for us to have
children and be able to just and it
might go all you know awry like because
we might they might because there's some
craziness to the way we're wired too you
know I'm saying that they might a little
too much love and not quite enough rigid
upbringing might make it where they just
go be hellions right we might go the
other way yeah but you know I just know
a lot of men that Polo Don Cliff
Kingsbury friends of mine that over 40
don't have kids you know put that
coaches Cardinals yeah yeah that's my
boy yeah really shout out to Cliff yeah
dude Cliff is a kid yeah we got to be
real cool when he was coaching the uh
Texas Tech before he he got that job man
you know that's that's a great fellow
right there man he seems real cool man
yeah man I'm saying every every area I
think Cliff Kingsbury should run for
president honestly gang bro I mean he's
just that kind of guy like man he he can
just relate to anybody he's a principal
guys principals don't get compromised
for anything you know I'm saying he
stands on what he stands for and uh you
know I'm just using him as an example
yeah you know what I'm saying he's a
brother of my mind like my friend but a
brother super producer produced 32 33
number one records you know you don't
have kids I don't I don't have kids you
don't have kids it's just that was
almost unheard of you know like in the
1950s or whatever you know you had Kevin
kids the only thing you did you know you
know I worry sometimes that honestly I
think I worry that if I did have kids
that there would be a a somehow do
the same thing I think well there's
probably some fear my girlfriend uh
was pregnant at one time this is like
2006. yeah like right around that same
New Booty time when everything was
coming to a head
and
she had a miscarriage at uh I think it's
like four months and um just in those
four months when I know the
way I felt ex thinking I was getting
ready to be a father
man
it's a different feeling man like he's
like I gotta get get my [ __ ] together
because I can let myself down you know
I'm saying but I can't let a Mini-Me
down you know what I'm saying I gotta I
gotta get it right get it tight for this
little Joker right here you know what
I'm saying I can't be playing about
another life that's you know I can only
imagine a child being born
in looking at that child and seeing
yourself in it like some physical thing
in your eyes or something just I can
only imagine how that would feel and I
never thought I wouldn't have kids but I
was kind of careful back in the
quote-unquote Heyday because I had so
many friends that have multiple baby
mamas and everybody's life was just
miserable when that was the case you
know what I'm saying like yeah three
baby mamas and you know they got two
other baby that you know what I'm saying
everybody yeah it's not good on it's
like Red Rover at Thanksgiving yeah so I
didn't want that I didn't I didn't want
to be a part of perpetuating that type
of deal and so I was you know and then
uh God bless my ex-wife I think maybe
with us just by the time we actually got
married maybe we were already kind of
coming unraveled and it just spiritually
just never lined up the right way
um
you think it'll still happen I haven't
given up and I don't I'm not too like
thrilled about the prospects of being 86
years old at my child's High School
graduation but you know my dad was 70
when I was born which is crazy man pops
that's what's up I only say that it's
because I keep finding myself talking to
guys who were we getting older and we
don't have any children yet so I started
I used to think my dad was crazy and I'm
like damn I just if I could beat him by
10 years just because we were just dream
chasing man like you know it's a good
point man you know what dream Chase it
was like other things to me seemed
boring bro right it was like and I could
go have a family I pop somebody had me
and they ain't doing [ __ ] out here I
could go [ __ ] do that in half hour if
I was right I felt that like I wanted
some Cree I wanted to like what can I do
I wanna I just did not I was scared to
death of being
in my 20s or something and feeling like
my whole life was planned out like okay
so I'm gonna do this for like 46 years
and then retire like oh my God like hey
much respect to anybody that works like
that because I'm not cut out for it you
know what I'm saying I'm not right right
I'm not saying uh yeah I'm not saying it
was horrible I'm just saying I'm not I
could not have done me you know what I
mean it just was not I would I would
have
if I didn't have create creativity you
know this Outlet of creativity that I
have with writing you know recording
music and stuff like I um
I would have probably already like
checked out of here you know what I'm
saying it's it's that vital to me and so
just to be able to live that way you
know I'm saying to make a living that
way crucial you know what I'm saying but
as I always tell people like man I'm I'm
gonna be 90 years old rapping like [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] what you like or
don't like like what you say about me
you know oh you're old
who cares like
still I made more money than you ever
gonna make your whole life but sorry I
had to I had to look good A lot of
people never get a chance to make
millions of dollars but my point is this
is like it's not a job it's not a hobby
it's not like
it's a he said to
the core of who I am is a function of my
spirit man like you know what I'm saying
it's yeah it's I remember Jay-Z had a
line where he said get a grip [ __ ]
that's how I get through life
you know but
how I get through life and how I always
related to that is
this you know what I'm saying this is
you know this was a
man it's just been so special like like
this this art form you know
shout out to those people you know the
black and brown people in in the Bronx
New York in the 70s that
you know we're doing what they was doing
and living the way they was living and
that all that form this perfect storm
that you know um
that this this music in this art form I
mean in his culture
you know sprung from man I'm just I'm so
grateful it found me
you know on a dirt road 20 minutes north
of LaGrange Georgia and it's kind of
wild huh changed my life man like you
know so I I honored that at every turn
you know I'm saying like there's nothing
I put ahead I think Hip-hop is a
religion I mean what aside from like the
quote unquote traditional religions name
something that's brought more people
together from different walks of life
worldwide
man it's it's had it's had quite an
impact on this globe man
you know yeah music music has yeah I
mean but but especially hip-hop because
like I said it's hip-hop Unified
you know maybe it was just part of the
just the timing of like
um when hip-hop kind of exploded you
know onto the scene but man it was just
a lot of like I said a lot of racist
Hearts potentially racist hearts that or
hearts that could have developed into
you know being exactly what their their
parents and their grandparents
you know and going on back down the line
where in the way they thought you know
what I'm saying but
um I know people you know that that
like I said it might just be that one
thing they could hang their hat on like
man I love right cast so much you know
what I'm saying I want to be racist but
damn yeah man like yeah because then you
because the lesson to be learned is yeah
like and the the lesson to be learned is
is you know what there's we're all human
you know what I'm saying so we all have
flaws and you can't then sweeping
indictments and Broad ass
generalizations you know what I'm saying
trying to lump everybody that looks a
certain way into any kind of you know
like bowl that just says all those
people are just like this
you know what I'm saying that's I know
there's no fruit on that tree I wish I
wish you could it would definitely make
things easier yeah but but you know I I
just don't
you know I I have brothers that that
look a lot of different ways Charlie's
my brother he's you know he's a black
guy you know what I'm saying I
I got a lot of black Brothers you know
what I'm saying I got some White
Brothers too you know I'm saying I got
some Mexican Puerto Rican Brothers you
know what I'm saying oh well yeah and so
you know that's I a brother to me is
someone that shares the same ideals and
principles that that I that I have that
I try to live yeah it's funny man I got
this new fitness guy or the this
athletic Coach man this black guy and
I've man I just love he's like I love
being around the dude bro yeah energy
man I mean he like he inspires me up he
inspires me he like and he's like one of
the best fish that's what a trainer's
gotta be too man you gotta make you just
want to be there like to be neared and
just get in get in the thick of this
[ __ ] with it yeah he does that but also
it's on like even more of just like uh I
don't know in general yeah it's like man
it makes me I feel inspired by him you
know man
um that's great man I know I love being
like that's really being inspired that's
my drug that's my true drug that's the
reason I would ever do drugs or you know
what I'm saying like because man if I
I'm inspired if man there's not much I
couldn't do bro you know I'm saying like
if I'm inspired I really feel like I
could have been president or something
like but if I'm not inspired you might
want to get somebody else to help you
carry the groceries in from the car yeah
you know I'm saying like I'm pretty
useless
at um so after so going through do you
feel like that having an addiction and
struggling with it that it had an effect
in your career do you feel like your
career has played out just kind of how
it yeah 100 because
um first of all right after new booty
and after that that because that was the
top one that was like uh oh no that was
the number one Record Man like like you
know my Wikipedia there's some I I don't
even look at your wicked but I've tried
to change stuff on there man like I
don't they change it back it's just
crazy they're [ __ ] that's a mafia
yeah I don't know what's going on with
that but anyway I'm not [ __ ] five
nine either
ass picture off of there bro my picture
is horrible bro bring my [ __ ] it's the
worst look at my Wikipedia dude I don't
look like Charlie decide who ugly you
know what I said whoever's running ugly
whoever controls the gates of my page I
must have [ __ ] their girlfriend or
something at some point like I'm sorry I
didn't know
oh
my god dude you look like a hit man at a
Asian Asian Toronto bro
Vladimir yeah you look like I'm in
America trying to kind of dress cool but
like it's like flea market [ __ ] like now
bring mine out there my [ __ ] looks
horrible too bro I look like I've been
struggling man
look at the other [ __ ] wrists it just
don't look like you I look mentally
[ __ ] bro no offense if anybody's
[ __ ] bro I mean yeah sometimes me
too
I just remember look at my look at them
cross side I look something wrong with
me I wonder how old that picture was
that's probably six years ago [ __ ] I
mean that that picture of me that's
another that's the [ __ ] up part about
it
you got a nice outfit on 2005 yeah but I
like you always say like he's like don't
ever shave your [ __ ] beard again like
that's what people say I'm like well
somebody should have told me that a
little earlier in this process there's a
lot of pictures out there I mean but
anyway and I had this egg head like I
used to have this I would be lazy and
not want to go to the to the like real
Barber I'm big on haircuts and [ __ ] now
but uh I just shave my own head all you
know like down oh yeah whatever yeah I
cut my hair for like probably 32 years
man yeah man you know but whenever I
could so probably only about 16 years
um but man you uh you don't look bad
there I feel like I look bad but I feel
like right there you just don't look
like you it just didn't that doesn't
even look like you yeah I went through a
period I was trying to fit in in
Hollywood and look more clean because
yeah you look like uh you know what you
look like you look like uh Dane Cook's
like little brother out of shape brother
or something yeah like Shane cook Shane
cook
book he don't look like Ray Liotta
right there
lately younger like Goodfellas Ray
Liotta I kind of see that yeah kind of
good
rest in peace I know nobody even cared
that he died bro that's just the world
we [ __ ] live in man nobody even cared
these days nobody's like it used to be
like this is like even a hit song now
man it's like you know it goes up yeah
it's like you get a week you know what
I'm saying and then everybody's on
something else well dude I remember we
went camping one time when I was a kid
with like a boy scouts or somebody I
don't know could have just been a damn
pedophile bro but we was outside
and uh I told everybody before we left I
said you know Jay Leno died
and they didn't have any social media
and so everybody the whole weekend was
like damn Jay Leno died man and people
were talking about it some guy some some
kid's dad was even crying about it and
then we got back and everybody's like
this [ __ ] lied bro but nobody
knew for three days but it was like wow
what's the point of doing that like I
think just I wanted to create some
Ambiance or something you know and uh
you want to create some like uh what do
you call it like uh not nostalgic but
like morale like everybody yeah we're in
this here let's do it for Jay huh and uh
but I don't know what I was even talking
about but um so take me through yeah so
let's just so I want to be able to
relate a lot of our audience struggles
with uh addiction and just different
things that's a lot of running a lot of
people do nowadays you know they were
saying the other day uh 70 of uh of
adults in America on one medication or
at least one medication
um so what effects did you feel like it
had on you uh it's a real deal all right
so the so when I first went to rehab and
I got out like that was the height of my
career you know what I'm saying I just
you know how hard was it to be in rehab
all your career was going well I mean
that's that's the time when I was like
like trying to [ __ ] everything that with
the with the vagina and breasts and
stuff like you know what I'm saying so I
was kind of on that tip like I remember
like but that's when I honestly when I
got over
um you know being a a homophobe you know
because
there were a lot of people you know I
kind of went down there on some arrogant
stuff I'm withdrawing and I'm like yeah
I heard y'all like to make people room
with gay people too put me on people put
me in a room with no games yeah I was
man I'm from I'm you know what I'm
saying I'm from the south man like I
ain't I'm I'm in a pretty enlightened
guy but I just I've never been around
any gay people to be honest with you oh
yeah yeah I remember we went around any
gays until you know so we fear what we
don't you know what we haven't been
exposed to what we don't understand what
just a certain like um
presentation and depiction of something
that we received and you know and one of
the you know coolest a couple of cool
cats that I was in in uh in treatment
with were gay man and they some of the
best people I've ever known oh yeah and
it just you know I'm saying it's like
I was always so focused on black folks
and white folks because that's really
what I was you know in the in the mud
with you know what I'm saying and so but
then I would be could be judgmental in
some other way to some other group of
people it just it was just so flaw of me
you know what I'm saying but but I'm
being around that experience and and uh
and meeting those guys and then
countless other gay folks since then
that I've had the pleasure of knowing
you know it's I'm just not [ __ ] up
with it I don't care as long as you
don't harm
um children elderly people mentally
handicapped people animals or just
people that can't defend themselves yeah
I'm not really judging a lot in this
world you know what I'm saying because I
don't know what the hell you've been
through you know I'm saying I don't know
what it's like inside your head and what
your experiences have shaped you into
into becoming you know I'm saying so but
there's just certain lines you can't
cross you know what I'm saying that's
just the way it is because yeah I feel
that way if you do we got to get you out
of here you know what I'm saying like
you can't be messing with children and
you know you just can't be
you know just just um recklessly go you
know just pillaging Humanity you know
helpless Humanity but um so after he
went to the rehab yeah I blamed the
music industry in music for so I went
two years without doing music
then I didn't go really go to the studio
one day I was going to NA meetings I
mean I was going to you know a 12-step
recovery meetings
and um were you getting better yeah I
was but but at the same time I wasn't
I was pretty much just I had some pretty
goodness at that time I had some pretty
good recovery
um but you know what it was man I just
wasn't
I was just sitting there
you know and it got to a point where I
started going to do shows and it was
kind of tormenting like you know going
in these clubs and
and it's not being that that uh
atmosphere of recovery internally just
it just got weaker and weaker and weaker
but it got to the point where
clean and sober like I really wanted to
check out here you know what I'm saying
because it just
I guess I just hadn't stuck around long
enough for the for that you know
spiritual change to happen or whatever
even though it was you know
a long time you know what I'm saying
over a year
and um
I don't know I just it just was really
really excruciating and I was just white
knuckling it and I mean finally I was
just
I had no it was either pick up a pistol
or pick up a drink you know and um but
you know I can I can say that like
you know I I then the next time it was
like drinking really became an issue you
know I'm saying I didn't go back to the
pills or anything like that but you know
being a an addict like I'll make
anything enough if that's if that's all
there is you know what I'm saying or if
I've got myself convinced that that's
all
um you know all that that I that I can
allow myself to do you know I can make
anything literally like sex you know
like any external thing man like if if I
like something
I'm probably gonna do it till it makes
me sick
yeah me yeah man I do that I can totally
relate to that man
I I will find anything to take me out of
the present moment you know to kind of
take me away from having to make ribs
are back for a month I'm just gonna eat
them until I vomit rib every you know
what I'm saying whatever you know what
I'm saying like I just oh man you had
that new this or that this new thing
Taco Bell's got you know I'm gonna go if
I like it I'm just gonna eat it until I
hate it yeah you know a person a woman
like come here oh I love you I love you
I love you you know what I'm saying like
oh we hate each other because you know
because when we're toxic and you know
we're we're like we're around each other
too much and you know what I'm saying
it's like we melt into each other and
you don't you've lost perspective on who
you are as a person you know because we
I just wanted to just
give me give me give me you know what
I'm saying fill up this hole inside of
me you know and and uh as I've learned
you know that hole can only be filled
with
you know the spiritual component really
like when that can mean a lot of
different things to a lot of different
people
but uh because really all I think all we
want is peace you know I just want some
peace man
you know at this point I I
don't know I just I know that I have
given a lot to my addiction you know
what I'm saying I I can't say I lost it
to my addiction I say you know I
volunteered you know yeah but um but at
the same time like I
I couldn't just because it's been what
it's been I couldn't imagine it any
other way you know what I'm saying
because I don't know
you know my best friend Big Steve always
says that
you know when he went into rehab the
first time and he's been he went to
rehab one time and he's been sober so oh
six so 16 years I mean he works in in
recovery oh wow yeah yeah
um and
he quit playing football
and you know and started a whole new
life and he says if I kept playing if I
hadn't just like abruptly just started a
whole new chapter he said I would have
been able to stay sober you know but me
because you don't it's not like Brett
Favre if your body starts letting you
down and you age out of you know making
music you're still in it yeah and so
like you know I
I kept going you know it's just like I
don't know what else to do it's like
you know it's just so it's ingrained in
me man it's just like I said a function
of my spirit and so then you start going
back to other parts you know of it as
far as like doing because I really the
studio I can handle
but it's it's that road man it's hard
yeah that road is what's gonna
ultimately always take me back back to
to drinking and you know then ultimately
some type of drug or whatever yeah you
know that's one of the toughest things
man I was uh I was in so much pain I
remember sitting in my in my garage one
day and saying man I'm just I wasn't
even doing anything I was just sick of
myself yeah I was like man I'm so
how do I I'm just I am literally
sick of myself man I love all I could
think about was myself and it was kill
it was just like I don't know what it
was man I'm so I I'm in awe of how great
I can be like how amazing I can be and
then I'm in awe of the piece of [ __ ]
that I can be as well you know what I'm
saying it's like
it's crazy man I just I I know other
people must be like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you man because like you know
because people the people closest to me
have been experiencing it just like I
have but even me I'm like what the [ __ ]
you know what I mean because I've never
the only thing I've ever been consistent
at is being inconsistent you know yeah
and uh I don't know what it is man it's
just something about something within me
it's like
uh I had a therapist shot originally
Richard Lee Nielsen in Atlanta he said
um he called it The Saboteur you know
what I'm saying like this there's just
something he said you just there's a
part of you
you know inside of you that just wants
you to be unhappy just there's a part of
you that wants you to be unhappy so like
that's like the self-destruct mechanism
like things are going great you know
what I'm saying met this new girl you
know got this new situ whatever things
are going great oh things are going
great I need to [ __ ] some [ __ ] up you
know I mean like and it's not a
conscious thing yeah it's not even a
conscious thing that's what's amazing
sometimes is I got this little
[ __ ] inside of me that wants to
you know just like to get a ride back up
it's the same reason why I told people
Jay Leno died man it really is bro man
but it really is it's because something
inside of me there needs to be
I need something to be messed up because
it's the oh yeah I gotta have somebody
to fight you know what I'm saying like
an idea that I'm fighting like that's
the if I don't have that I'm pretty much
useless like if you I gotta have that
edge you know what I'm saying something
to light that fire you know what I'm
saying and I I made up stuff and tricked
myself into thinking [ __ ] or whatever
like just to come on let's get going but
yeah that's crazy man but it's funny
because it's it might be just
this is exactly the way ever that's why
a lot of times I believe I am exactly
where I'm supposed to be because even if
I behave that way that's the same way I
behaved that got me to where yeah
exactly
exactly the double-edged sword you know
what I'm saying I think about that all
the time too it's like that it serves us
and it just it destroys us too like it's
like balance I think is the thing that
if we have like an ultimate purpose as
far as internally what I feel like we're
supposed to accomplish
uh while we're here is to learn some
balance you know what I'm saying like in
some some discipline you know like they
say we we're going to suffer pain it's
either the pain of discipline or the
pain of regret and I've suffered the
pain at discipline at times and I and I
reap the benefits and I and and I've not
been disciplined at times you know and
and I've read unavoidably yeah the pain
of regret man yeah it's hard man it's
also hard you know it's not also like
it's easy but I I man I can just totally
you know and nobody's got like everybody
is is saddled with something you know
what I'm saying so just because a person
doesn't have the same issues that I have
and that's that's you know that's true
humility you know what I'm saying is
that self-awareness of understanding it
you know I used to think humility was
like acting inferior when you really
thought you were Superior like being
sheepish like oh no this whole thing you
know just whatever like no I'm not I'm
not cute whatever the [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying just not be not taking
compliments well all that kind of [ __ ]
like that's being humble to me you know
what I'm saying like
um but I've come to learn you know as
I've grown and experienced life that
um humility is more like just kind of
like a true understanding of self like I
got some good qualities about me you
know I'm saying I got some good [ __ ]
going on man but also got some some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like that I need to work
on you know what I'm saying and I'm in
the process with it with working on
those things yeah and I'm okay with
where I'm at and I understand that I'm
no better or worse than anybody else you
know what I'm saying people just have
some people don't ever identify their
strengths you know or you know they it
doesn't register with them that dang
this is how I can benefit from my
strengths you know what I'm saying like
I can make a living or help others or
whatever you know what I'm saying and so
they just never turn them up or like
shine that light on them and get them
all the way you know hitting on all
cylinders
but you know I I've just been in
instances where other people you know
like I'm good in a social setting you
know what I'm saying like a [ __ ] I'm a
cocktail party Superstar you know what I
mean like you know just I can shoot the
[ __ ] with anybody man I get that from my
pops man and um and so people that
aren't good in those types of settings
that aren't like personable people like
that
I used to kind of maybe like look down
on them a little bit like oh man you
just ain't fly with it like me you know
what I'm saying like until I was in a
situation I'm not going to speak on what
the what the situation exactly what
entailed but
where I was completely lost and a person
that maybe I looked down on because they
didn't have a social quote unquote
social skills that I had was in their
element and it saved my ass big time
you know what I'm saying and it just
that just further like hammered that
point home like we all we all got some
[ __ ] that that we're good at you know
I'm saying we all got some [ __ ] we need
to work on man we're all humans you know
it's
and we're all going to need each other
yeah I mean I promise you we are man I
know I promise you you know what I'm
saying it's just like any time whatever
group that you say you know like they're
the problem I promise you you're gonna
be in a situation where you need
somebody from that group I promise you
I've seen it too many times I mean it's
just that's just the way the universe
sorts [ __ ] out or God's Source things
out like however you want to look at
that you know but I've seen it pop up
repeatedly in in my life and just you
know other people that wanted to be
judgmental you know because we just we
all it makes us feel better to some
degree to be able to just blame other
people for you know something that is
not going right you know in our own
lives but you know it's [ __ ] life's
just gonna life man yeah and it's
interesting like you said in the
beginning like if you could look at life
through a whole spectrum of time it's
unfortunate we're only able to see life
a lot of times or a lot of us are just
as right now we're not able to see the
past 3 000 years we're not able to see
it it's always right now right and if we
could get a whole if we could really
spend life like this and look at the
Spectrum of things it would give us all
a unique perspective and maybe that's
the perspective that's coming along in
the future like you were saying yeah
because I think even like when I was
talking about like visiting battlefields
of old battles and stuff I think this
obviously becomes like a sicko element
to it they just go back and just like
they're just there with like this hot
chick or something you know what I mean
I'm gonna take this brought out to the
uh
now this Joker's gonna figure out not
even that though but like people going
back in time like jerking off yeah type
[ __ ] oh
dang bro that's gonna be sad man but
that's just humans man but you're gonna
have some dude going back ultimate
Beauty humans humans we Encompass the
ultimate Beauty you know what I'm saying
like in the ultimate [ __ ] ugliness
man it's like you know our greatest gift
is probably like if if you were some
like evolved like alien species you know
what I'm saying look just looking at us
you'd be so envious of the fact that we
can feel the way we feel because if
you'd evolved before you can't even feel
yeah you don't have there's no love
there's no emotion in you it's all just
like logic and survival you know what
I'm saying yeah imagine the alien comes
back just to see like a mother hug a
child yeah or to see somebody crying
because their girlfriend broke up with
them yeah and they can't even have tears
and they've actually evolved into just
being one gender and they they like
spawn Every Spring and that's how the
new you know the new the gene pool like
that's how the new new people come yeah
like so there's no it's just one gender
like it evolved into that like that's
ultimately what it feels like we're kind
of being prompted towards I know you
know but um somebody come all the way
back in time just to see a breast or uh
somebody's dick yeah because they don't
have it just envious or just like but
also like man y'all are stupid as hell
yeah yeah you know what I mean y'all
feel [ __ ] why y'all want to feel [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah that's so played out man
look at these people still feel it
that's why y'all keep them blowing up
[ __ ] and doing their things y'all be in
your house feelings and [ __ ] you know so
there's something to be said for you
know you couldn't imagine a life without
emotion and feelings and because it kind
of is what drives us you know what I'm
saying but
I mean it's it's it's just a
double-edged sword that pretty much
comes along with anything if you think
about it like dude I think uh you have
such a
I just am fascinated by your perspective
man the the perspectives you've been
able to live through and the perspective
that you've been able to uh
um
not create for yourself but uh
learn and evolve into as you've as
you've uh don't rule anything out man
and I just I I'm teachable you know what
I'm saying that's one thing that I
committed to to always just be coachable
and teachable because please present me
with some I beg anyone out there present
me with some new information that either
improves upon some bad or dated
information that I'm using you know I'm
saying like please give me some new
information if my information's wrong I
welcome it I encourage it I need it you
know what I'm saying so and and
sometimes it may not come from the
people that you would want it to come
from and the way you would want it to
come but hey I can't tell help how to
help me you know what I'm saying like so
you know and that's just and it's just
about I just wish more people would just
be unconditionally open-minded you know
because
man it's just I you know I I got into
astrology recently you know or in the
past couple years and really started uh
learning more about it even though for
most of my life I was like you know
whatever I just use it as a way to pick
up girls what's yourself what's your
sign or look at this a conversation
starter but look at that start starting
to make sense to me that in the future
it could be certain aspects of astrology
could be looked at as science because it
only makes sense to me that now if you
were born at a certain time of year in a
certain place the air pressure was you
know this at that time the humidity
level like all these things that we may
not know they could have a major impact
on on the way a human
mind and body and spirit develops you
know I just think it is that it's going
to be in the future at some point it's
going to be a lot more Credence to stuff
like that you know what I'm saying like
and and I think whereas
um religion
not religion I don't even religion is
just a man-made in my opinion just
something that
man-made as a way to you know to try and
connect to a higher power yeah but but
but I don't even think it was that I
think man can connect to a higher power
Yeah by himself you know by herself but
I think in in some ways religion was
just to control people you know what I'm
saying it's like
um when you look at like various
religious institutions I mean it's hard
to say that
I what they say in that movie the um
The DaVinci Code or something like oh
yeah I just watched well he was like he
was like um
asking a guy about God and he said no
don't tell me what what man has told you
about God tell me what you think about
God you know what I'm saying and it's
like
man it's like anything I'm told by a man
I'm just I'm just no men are flawed you
know I'm saying men and women are very
flawed so you know who knows what kind
of [ __ ] might be attached to you
know the reason that they're telling me
this you know that's not to say that I'm
just would rule it out but it's just to
say I can't just accept it it's just
what it is it's my concrete fundamental
truth yeah you know but you know
religion's helped a lot of people you
know what I'm saying and you know my I
come my mother and father are Christian
you know and I and I I'm a Christian I
would say you know what I'm saying but
um I'm just not gonna just
you ain't gonna just piss down my back
tell me it's raining me be like okay no
it's raining yeah you know I'm gonna
investigate things for myself I'm gonna
think for myself oh yeah some of that's
piss yeah for sure yeah yeah
it's warm and why three y'all standing
back there man why three or four y'all
been drinking damn beer all day like
y'all ain't got out the pool one time
bro I've got you and Riff Raff gotta get
together and talk man I would listen to
that for hours I love to talk to him man
yeah that sounds so much like the same
we gotta get up man for reals dude uh
yeah I just I feel so grateful to have
gotten to spend time with you and
um yeah it means a lot man that we
finally got to do this because it's a
long time coming for sure yeah we should
go grab something y'all gonna eat or
something yeah love to get something to
eat we'll go right down the street if
you want to check out more music what
else is what else can we they expect I
mean honestly I've I've put out music
with the exception of the two years that
I was I was talking about which really
set me back because that was the time
when the internet was starting to
dictate uh music musical styles and
Trends evolving in a much more rapid
rate so and that was like the worst time
to take two years off so it took me a
while to just get caught up and and
honestly I feel like I'm better now than
I've ever been you know I was blessed to
work with some really great producers
early on and and so I was good you know
always but I benefited from working with
some great people you know what I'm
saying whereas now I'm kind of like able
to be a more self-contained entity you
know almost I can go in the studio by
myself and and and right ahead you know
what I'm saying like every aspect of it
but um I'm putting out music pretty
consistently man like I'm about to I'll
get kind of liking a love for a year or
so you know maybe do some other stuff
and then just at some point I'm gonna
get robbed back up on it man because it
just calls me you know I'm saying it's
is is that real to me and you know
you're fortunate as long as I'm
breathing on this planet if you if you
like listening to my music if it just
doesn't make you vomit you know what I'm
saying I the good news is I'm as long as
I'm breathing as long as my mental
faculties will allow me to do so I'm
going to be rapping are there other uh
yeah because there's no one that sound
there is no one
still that sounds like you I was
listening to a bunch of your music this
week and there was uh there's I can't
even explain it and I don't think Nick
it needs to be explained that's why well
you know man it's like what I like about
the way you do your thing man is it's
like
honestly the first episode I ever saw
was Boosie oh yeah and it was just dope
man I was like this is weird to me like
why is like this is just strange to me
and then you started talking and
realizing from Baton Rouge like
everything and I was like this is
[ __ ] New South as [ __ ] man this is
like dope as hell you know what I'm
saying I started getting into just the
the authentic way because look every
person has ever been born into this
world
has something unique about them that
sets them apart from every other person
that's ever been born into this world
you know what I'm saying we all have
something in us that just separates us
from everybody else doesn't make us
better or worse just makes us us and to
me great art whether you're a
quarterback a painter you know a
musician a comedian great art is about
the ability to make whatever it is that
makes you unique and different from
everybody else and special translate
into your art you know what I'm saying
and and so I just really get off when I
when I encounter people or when I'm able
to observe cats that are doing that you
know what I'm saying it's like dang man
like nobody can compete with that you
know I'm saying if you just truly like
get in your own lane
the even the attempt to compete with it
is a loss you know what I'm saying it's
like you know you just can't be another
person you know and we're all inspired
and influenced by by others that's not
to say you know I have influences many
influences I get influenced by things
every day and I'm not scared to like I
said acknowledge that give me some new
information like you know inspire me in
a different way whatever yeah but to
really be it's that's the scariest thing
I think is to try and be yourself and
that's so fascinating yeah so so when
you do finally learn who you really are
and embrace it and accept it you cherish
it man you know what I'm saying you
cherish it like and and you definitely I
I'm I'm sympathetic and empathetic to
people that that haven't been able to to
discover themselves or or embrace you
know who they truly are because
I know people's out here they can't that
haven't been able to do it for
themselves so they they they uh vent
that that angst from not being able to
to figure it out for themselves by you
know judging and throwing stones at
other people you know that and that's
just the way it's gonna go man you know
it's just
hurt people hurt people but I would a
lot of people get people lost yeah
I would love to see you I feel like you
have such a calling to be able to just I
mean you always you're already doing it
but your ability to communicate man it's
really strong and it's not a I didn't
know I I didn't have a super strong idea
of what you would be like as a human
outside of what I've seen of you I've
done a pretty bad job honestly of just
you know I've I've kind of hidden you
know it's been it's been a rough you
know like I'd say last five years and I
just you know us being you know the way
we are is as you know addicts or or
whatever it is that we're saddled with
or blessed with however you want to look
at that we isolate you know what I mean
oh yeah man you know and I I get away
from from people and places and things
or anything that could potentially cause
more discomfort you know that that
gnawing self-centered fear that fear of
nothing in particular is just like if I
go out there I'm gonna melt you know
like just baseless but yeah and I'm and
you know I got some some good people I
work with Charlie you know so I saw a
brother of mine my boy Boogie Jason like
just people that are some good people
around me man when
um when not necessarily some people left
me a lot of people left some were
Justified some work
um but there were also a lot of people
that
I walked away from you know what I'm
saying I withdrew from everything and
everybody at a certain point and so the
people that were still around me like
and they weren't tapped that's not
something they signed up for you know
what I'm saying to to be have this
responsibility of [ __ ] like salvaging
or trying to get you know what I mean oh
yeah yeah we're confusing folks man you
know and it's like and it's like all I
can ever promise somebody like that is
the goods going out way too bad but you
know it's it's um I just been blessed
man like that man sitting over there man
I would not be here on this planet
breathing really he saved you a couple
times I mean not like not like not like
Narcan you know but just you know what
I'm saying like just there was nobody
else yeah there was just nobody else he
was just ended up you know with that
baton
um you know and it's sad because I don't
know sometimes if I could do that is if
I'm real I don't I don't know if I could
love somebody that you know cares oh he
didn't I mean he'll trust me he didn't
want to like he I think he at certain
times you know daylight we done been
into it you know and and uh but he you
know he ain't perfect either you know
what I'm saying so it's like sometimes
sometimes the quote-unquote sick one can
you know can yeah yeah the sick one got
to be there for the sick yeah you know
because we all just some old stupid ass
Human [ __ ] man dude I won't let
I'll tell you this I won't listen to
well people a lot of times I can only
hear it that sounds like somebody that's
bullshitting to me like a whale person
yeah I gotta hear from somebody that's
sick we was talking about that last
night we were talking about how you know
it's that therapeutic value you know of
one act helping another like when you
know somebody's been through that [ __ ]
you know the same you know and and just
attraction over promotion you know just
we were just talking about all these
these different principles and Concepts
and and uh yeah I can I you know God
bless anybody this this is coming from a
good place and trying to help but I
really can only be helped by somebody
that I that can relate you know because
I've just
you know we just feel like terminally
unique and was it terminally unique and
fatally cool or something like that like
yeah basically like I as I've always
felt like not
did they just
I couldn't just relate to people that
that just hadn't experienced like a and
we all experienced pain that's not what
I'm saying but it's almost like a
somebody that's like with inflict pain
on themselves like we do you know what
I'm saying it's like you know yeah I'm a
superior I'm a superstar with an
inferior or do you have like something
like well I'm a people pleaser that
don't give a [ __ ] when nobody thinks
about me
that's the real deal but the ego Maniac
with the inferiority company I'll get
inferiority complex man just a crazy
song [ __ ] a lot of us are out there man
and a lot of us don't even know that we
have this that you know that they that
they have some element of it you know in
my old sponsor again used to say that he
was the people that pick up the drug or
the drink or whatever got the Blessed
ones because that gets us that much
closer to the solution whether we pick
it up or not right but some people go
through their whole lives and they never
find the thing that brings everything to
a head where they do identify the fact
that they got some [ __ ] wrong with them
you know saying so they just go through
their lives red Restless irritable and
discontent and no idea why you know what
I'm saying God that is a that is almost
like a hell yeah I mean hell I know I
know
some people very close to me I would say
they fall into that category and there's
just nothing and they'll talk at you all
day about you know what I mean like you
know you just got to be strong and all
this stuff you know but it's like
I'm just sitting there seeing the
quote-unquote disease like I'll manifest
itself in in that person's life and and
that's just not even a conversation
they're willing because they attach it
to the drug you know what I'm saying
right you know what I mean really that's
just a symptom
you know what I'm saying the proc it's
the it's the US problem you know what
I'm saying oh I never had an issue with
drinking man I never I like I didn't
like drinking I had to go pee like we
probably all have two right now I had to
go pee bro and I I hated having to go
pee because I didn't want to miss being
around people right and so I never liked
drinking man wow now I like something I
did start to like cocaine because it and
drinking was it took too long to feel
some type of way I wanted to cocaine was
like you could feel this you could feel
this that hangover is awful though oh
yeah it was horrible but I never so it
took me so long to realize that I had
all these alcoholisms that I had all
this
silver meat yeah it took it because
there was no like it was so hard to pin
the tail on the donkey man yeah um
because you want to attach it to a
certain substance or something you know
really it's just that's your solution
for a while you know what I'm saying
whatever you pick up that that gambling
that food it's at First It's Your
solution it it quiets the the Beast you
know saying yeah because I don't want to
sit here with myself I don't want to sit
in the [ __ ] moment bro because at
some point in my life when I was a kid
or a baby or whatever the moment wasn't
it wasn't good for me right so it was
not a safe place to be so anything that
keeps me
because the moment can see you clearly
the moment is a [ __ ] mirror you know
and I don't want to be right there man
because I don't you know I mean we can
go all day about it I literally just
thought that made me break out in a
switch we could go on we could go all
day about no doubt yeah but look man I'd
love to chat again sometime and I just
think you have such a uh
I'm I feel grateful to have heard some
of the things you said today and I mean
that yeah I appreciate that um and I'm
glad that you know you don't need to
isolate because we need you
thank you man
thank you for real Theo thank you for
giving me this opportunity yeah dude you
you coming in man I've had so many
people that were so excited bro so it's
a blessing man you know cause you know
that's another thing too is just you
know in your head you're like oh nobody
I got this thing where I think people
when I at my shows that people paid just
because they hate me like it's it's
sickness you know yeah other sickness so
I don't think nobody gets down what I
got to say or nothing you know that's
just where it takes me you know what I'm
saying but it's good it's good to hear
that it's good to hear you say all those
kind of things yeah man I just think
because there's not
you there's no other you man like you
said a minute ago
there's nothing I mean I look when I was
listening to some of your verses couple
days ago and it's like
nobody has whatever this is now they
have different versions of it and [ __ ]
and they got newer and older versions
and they got some things I don't have
right agree yeah but but I got some I
mean you know it was yeah I mean you
know I I hey I'm blessed you know and we
all are you know what I'm saying that's
the unique that's the great thing about
you know the the way humans are set up
where our accounts are set up you know
it's like man if you just we all got
some qualities man that can that can be
redeemable you know what I'm saying it
can we just gotta you know what we feed
will flourish and what we starve will
die you know
in our own Spirits yeah man I gotta uh I
gotta start feeding the good spots man
we all do we we all gotta you know
saying that's gotta be vigilant as far
as that goes God damn sure I'll tell
myself a [ __ ] up story oh and what
let's say whatever story you're telling
yourself is true you know so
um I know and I get tired of living my
old story man
that's what you know I'll get tired
sometimes I start to realize man is this
you know whether it was your story or
whether it was your truth or not growing
up how long you want to keep telling
yourself that just because of what it
makes you feel like this is just who you
are this is just what it is you know
what I'm saying that's the big you know
that's the biggest cop out you know and
I'm very guilty of it you know it's
resignation almost but it's like but
it's hard when it's giving you also the
the Flint and the steel because you feel
like you're gonna lose yeah you know
what I mean if I turn if I if I diminish
any aspect of it then it's all gone if I
don't have my story then who the [ __ ]
even am I and it's kind of it's kind of
happened to me like that before too like
I just I'd rather die than I'd rather
keep going Way Beyond the gates of
insanity in Hell than just sit there
mundane and just like that ain't it bro
like that's not you know and and like I
said sometimes maybe I didn't put in
enough work you know what I'm saying
inside the you know the pro whatever you
know what I'm saying and so I didn't
ever reach that point where I could feel
that peace and that freedom and and
still have my good [ __ ] and then it's
our ongoing process even from there it's
not like it just it just happens one day
and you're just like oh I'm good now no
then it's an ongoing process too and
it's like how much do I want to take
care of myself because there's a part of
me that don't ever want to take care of
myself because it ain't even my [ __ ]
job to do it and that's the part too
inside of me sometimes that uh this is
somebody else's job why do I have to do
it every day you know I still think like
that sometimes and some of that shit's
hard to kill bro
um but I feel like I was in nine
meetings today no that's what I feel
like too bro I feel like that too man
and I've been in the program for five
and a half years six years and I've only
I'm still I just got to step nine two
days ago that's crazy so we'll see you
know the particular Fellowship I was in
like just the steps are worked slower
you know what I'm saying you know uh
with the workbook and stuff and and uh
that's the fellowship I prefer but I
know like you know some of those some
you know other Fellowship chips you know
what I'm saying like they you know how
he's doing the old days like you worked
all 12 steps over the weekend you know
what I mean but
um you hear stories about that yeah I
mean you know because it's it when you
break it down to its simplest form you
know what what the the steps are
actually trying to accomplish
um it's really not that complex a
process you know what I'm saying it's
just
um you know cleaning up and you know and
and um yeah trusting in God yeah and
cleaning house cleaning house you know
doing taking a real realistic inventory
yourself trying to make amends for the
wrong you've done you know and and then
trying to help other people that's it
that's it will you help me today Bubba
Sparks thanks so much for spending time
bro thank you Theo much love brother hey
man tell riff raff I'm I'm honest I'm
looking forward I'm gonna send him this
link he'll [ __ ] love it he'll love it
he's one of us hey look he loved to hear
his name you know he loved to hear
people care about him man there's no
this is it's a joke that me and him
hadn't you know that we hadn't uh
connected already because I know we got
several mutual friends and stuff so yeah
y'all have to man thanks again bro much
love
[Music]
feel I'm falling like these leaves I
must be
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life out I can
feel
it in the bones
but it's gonna take